this is Jocko podcast number 226 with
echo Charles and me Jocko will Inc good
evening echo good evening and also
joining us tonight is Dave Burke good
evening Dave good evening
alright so almost a year ago almost a
year ago I put out a podcast podcast is
number 174 and it was about the
evaluation system that's used in the
Marine Corps I talked about the
Navy and you might want to go and listen
to podcast 174 first before you continue
listening to this podcast but I wouldn't
say it's mandatory but in that in that
podcast I told a story and it was about
a guy that worked for me and he came to
me because he didn't have the highest
grades on the evaluation the Navy
evaluation system the grades go from one
to five five being the best one being
the worst and you know he was like an
average guy you know 3.3 or 3.6
something like that but he thought he
should have been better and so he came
to me set up a meeting you know which
was kind of weird because most people
didn't set up meetings to see me they
were just come and see me but he set up
a meeting with the admin department to
come see me and you know thought he
thought he should have been five-o a lot
of stuff and so as I'm talking to him
I'm kind of thinking how can I explain
to this guy that he's not a five-o and
so what I ended up doing was reading him
some of the bullets that would some of
the bullet points that would make you a
five-o how they describe a five-o seller
things like going to the go into the
document here professional knowledge
recognized expert sought out by all for
technical knowledge uses knowledge to
solve complex technical problems meets
pqs advancement requirements early and
with distinction they think about that
recognized expert sought out by all but
that means no one is above you in terms
of expertise in your view
mm-hmm and I'm looking at this guy who
like I said was a strong average and as
I said that to him he realized that
wasn't him mm-hmm and then it was like
quality of work needs no supervision
always produces exceptional work
no rework required maximizes resources
now think about these terms
always and exceptional there's not too
many people that go that's what you need
to be to be in five Oh category always
produce exceptional work that's not hey
these four out of five projects were
really good
we're exceptional even know it's five
four five you know who is doing this you
know does five four five like that not
this guy mmm military bearing in
character what does it take to be a 5.0
in military bearing and character it
takes exemplary personal experience
model of conduct on and off duty leader
in physical readiness exemplifies Navy
core values honor courage and commitment
let's just face it when it comes to the
word Honor there's you're throwing that
out there and you're saying hey I'm the
maximum grade and honor that's a bold
statement and not too many people are
running around making that statement and
then there's the leadership bullet to be
a 5.0 in leadership in the Navy you have
to you have to achieve the following
inspiring motivator and trainer
subordinates reach highest level of
growth and development superb organizer
great foresight develops process
improvements and efficiencies leadership
achievements dramatically further
command mission and vision persevere
through the toughest challenges and
inspires others exceptional communicator
makes subordinates safety conscious
maintains top safety record constantly
improves the personal and professional
lives of others come on
that's that's legit right and you know
so after reading this guy all through
this different criteria
he realized he wasn't a 5.0 sailor and
then on that podcast 174 I went deep
into the Marine Corps evaluation system
which is a superior document it's a
superior document and I was looking at
him today you know that the Navy one is
front and back it's two pages its front
and back the Marine Corps one is six
pages so three pages running back more
comprehensive and what it does it does a
similar thing which is set like the
ultimate standard for what the highest
level qualified marine would be and they
have this Christmas tree thing that I
talked about a podcast 174 and it's at
the highest level there's a one that
would be like the star on the Christmas
tree and then as you get into the middle
of the categories that there's more more
Marines because there's more Marines
that are you know high average and
there's even more that are just average
Marines but then the funny thing is the
stuff the bottom of the Christmas tree
it's not a bell curve it's not like even
on both ends at the like the the lowest
ranking Marine or the the lowest ranked
Marine there's just one of them like
loser Marines is a very small category
but what they describe that one person
that one marine at the top they describe
that marine as the eminently qualified
marine very powerful document and it
does like sets out in no uncertain terms
the qualities and behaviors that a
Marine it has to exemplify in order to
be a eminently qualified marine and you
know I actually I think I originally
called you Dave to say did I talk to you
about this in Ramadi and it ended up not
being you here like now I never talked
to you about that because I was in the
brigade Tactical Operations Center and I
was in there for whatever and I was
you're talking it must have been it it
was obviously was another marine who was
sitting there writing yeah writing evals
for someone his part
my boss yeah and he was sitting there
doing whatever and I started I just
picked up the document we were talking
about whatever and I just immediate
going before and as soon as I saw the
eminently qualified marine and putting
this together you can see the wheels are
spinning him I'm like this is legit and
I talked to you about it and the fact of
the matter is that in order to become
something well then you have to have
clear guidance on what you need to do to
become that thing and so that's what we
covered on that podcast and I closed out
by talking about the fact that we as
people as human beings don't really have
any documentation like that it doesn't
really exist and that was that was a big
thing that I learned as a young seal was
the first time that somebody sat me down
and read those descriptions to me I said
yeah you know what I got some room to
grow but it wasn't until I saw what the
highest level qualification was that I
had realized I had room to go because
you know you're 22 years old and you
think you're awesome until you see what
awesome actually is like so before I
even recorded that podcast when I talked
to you Dave and I was like hey was this
you and you're like I don't think so and
I said well we'll probably could have to
do something with us cuz this is gonna
leave a mark on people and and it did
and it did and it's I've been got more
also an incredible amount of feedback on
that podcast people have done podcasts
about that podcast and I told you that
we were gonna have to do something to to
assemble some kind of document where
people could grade themselves to try and
become an eminently qualified human
being and that was over that was almost
a year ago we have been eminent failures
at getting it done but the wait is over
and it is now available on Amazon it is
called the code the evaluation in the
protocols which is and look I was going
to say it's a weird name for a book but
it's actually it's me
be not fully classified as a book maybe
it's a handbook because it's not super
long it's not some grand articulation
but I did add we had to start with the
code the evaluations and then added the
protocols in that allows someone to try
and realize what it is like to create a
vision of what of the human that you
want to be and on the first podcast I
only talked about evaluations but then
as we put this together I started
thinking to myself that in order to
follow evaluations you need objectives
to achieve you need some kind of rules
you need some kind of some kind of code
and you know part of this is from the
fact that I wrote way the warrior kid in
the new warrior kid I got all kinds of
feedback about the warrior kid code
including that one guy that wrote the
with one of the few things I've read on
the podcast which was remember the guy
that wrote hey have lost this much
weight and I've got a promotion and he
turned his life around and then at the
end he said and the book I ran was where
the warrior kid so look and explained
this way of the warrior kid that warrior
cultures have codes that they try and
live by and I did the codes from the
Rangers and the Marine Corps and the
SEAL Teams and the code of bushido and
the code of chivalry and there's a
reason that those codes existed and and
the code that I wrote in there for the
way the warrior kid is a kids code but
the book encourages kids to make their
own code and this book does the same
thing but you know this gives you a
place to start so we came up with the
general categories to evaluate your
progress towards this code and then the
last part is about the protocols and
again this was just another thing that
kind of came out of the podcast of me
talking about protocols and I think the
first time I talked about we need a
protocol people need a protocol was you
break up with your girlfriend
and I went on this thing and I said
here's the protocol you order a pizza
you get extra cheese and sausage you
know Hugh you take two days of being
miserable you complain about it to your
friends and then you get up you work out
you move on you know like here's a
protocol that you follow and a bunch of
people were saying yes we need the
protocol and I've also talked about the
protocols the fact that in America since
we have so many different cultures all
mixed together we don't really have a
good protocol anymore for death and so
when someone dies you know in some
places in the world I always think of
Ireland then you know they have a
protocol like you're gonna the you're
gonna go to this pub you're gonna go to
this wake you're gonna perform this
religious service you're gonna do this
that they go through that protocol and
then they move on and different
religions have that but in America since
we have all this everyone kind of
consolidated together we lost some of
that so there's some sometimes people
don't know what the protocol is when
someone dies so there's another
situation where something happens and it
would be really good if you could follow
a protocol so we added some protocols to
get people through certain scenarios in
life and Dave and then Sarah Armstrong
as well who is a friend of mine a very
successful businesswoman very successful
business leader and a up in a long time
just old school oh gee trooper straight
up and you all helped me put this
together
and we ended up with this book so what
did I miss Dave no that's it man I mean
when we first did the podcast
I think we had the sense that we were
just gonna kind of replicate that and as
we started to really dig into what this
looked like we realized we need to have
something else in it that's where the
protocols really came from is this sort
of tells you what you can be but we
realize there's a whole bunch of things
you have to do it was pretty cool look
there's no way it should have taken me
this long but we did figure out along
the way there was more needed to go into
that we needed to write a code and we
needed to figure out what some of those
protocols are to help people understand
the things they needed to do so so here
we are alone Muslim
yeah I guess we've been busy and instead
of prioritizing and executing properly
we failed so anyways here we go
the book let's go to the book the book
is called the code the evaluation the
protocols striving to become an
eminently qualified human so the book is
out on a publishing company called
Chacko publishing and what's cool about
that is look we turned it if if this was
a normal publishing route to the year it
took us to get it done added another
year so the other thing that's cool
about it is when you open the front
cover it says first a dish literally
it's first a dish see see yes
so we got first a dish and let's roll
into it starts off the first section is
called the code and the whole book is
less than 100 pages and not a ton of
writing not needed the code here we go
without an objective the objective will
not be reached without a goal the goal
will not be achieved without a standard
the standard will not be met without a
mission the mission cannot be
accomplished without an ideal the ideal
will never be realized without a clear
path the path cannot be followed now
that's pretty simple and straightforward
but how many people do you know that are
going through life without an objective
without a goal without a standard
without a mission without a without an
ideal or without a path mmm right
they're everywhere they're everywhere
so continue yet we as human beings often
go through life without any of these and
so we wander we wander aimlessly without
making moving without making any
progress days months and years pass us
by time is wasted which means life is
wasted
you don't think about that do you that
when you waste time you're wasting life
and when was it I was talking about the
fact that I don't know when I was
talking about this maybe it was on the
podcast maybe was to a client but if you
take all this time that you wasted and
you were able to physically pile it up
hmm and see it and how you feel sick to
your stomach after two or three years to
see just this pile of wasted time so
when any waste time life is wasted and
potential is wasted our own potential
squandered meandering through life
instead of becoming who we could be
instead of attaining our highest
possible manifestation of being we
simply become whatever we become we fall
short in so many ways we fall short well
that's what happens that's what happens
it happens to all kinds of people
happens to me what I fail to do what I
should be able to do you know I was
thinking about this the other day if you
got something in your head if you've got
some idea in your head some thought some
dream some some something that you want
to create and you don't execute on that
that is a mortal sin think about that
mm-hmm you got something in your head
you got some idea you got you got this
thought that wants to come out but you
don't have the discipline to get it out
and you let this thing die inside your
head that is that is a mortal sin that's
my opinion
you got to get it out sorry little
tangent there that that's that's that's
what I think about though yeah just the
saying when we wrote this is you simply
become whatever we become is such a
failure to think that if we don't do
that thing you just described we just
become well I don't know what we've
become we become whatever and I think
part of the reason I got I think I got
more feedback on 174 that podcast and
more people reaching out asking about it
than any of the podcast we did because
this that struck a chord of people that
and you weren't even on it you had
mentioned the Marine Corps and what how
does the Marine Corps do this and people
were asking me and went and I think very
shortly after that you mentioned we were
gonna do something write something about
it I think people I mentioned it on the
podcast people are asking how do i
download you know the Marine Corps like
Google Marine Corps performance
evaluation but I was getting questions
all the time about that podcast because
people wanted to know how the Marine
Corps did this and making the connection
between that and themselves because I
think this idea of if you don't become
what you're gonna become
you're gonna become whatever and there
actually is criteria out there which was
the crazy part is we put a little
thought into this was how many people
how many times have I just done whatever
I did which sucks so bad to think about
that yeah and the this what this book
right here this little 96 page or
whatever it is book right to not put
this out is wrong totally it's wrong
it's wrong we had to put it out and you
know what it's not easy it's a pain
there's a bunch of iterations you're
sending me edits you know it's all just
a pain right but if you let it sit there
and just die you're wrong you're
committing a sin yeah and not just for
yourself but for your family for the
people around you for god knows how many
number people that could actually
benefit from that effort you put into
creating something that won't just help
you but it could help everybody yeah and
you know what I guess what must scare
people is they might think well you know
what if I do this actually this is
probably more excuse than anything else
stuff well what if I do isn't no one
really
mm-hmm and I've said that some people
some people's have I really want to
start a podcast and then they'll say
something like or I really want to write
a book and they say but you know I'm
really not sure if anyone would be
interested in or you know whatever and I
always say if you're writing it or
you're recording it so that other people
will listen to it you're already
starting off on a bad foot because if
that's your read look you need to write
it for or write it or record it or do
whatever because it wants to come out
because you need to get it out there and
then the world can judge it however the
world judges it which is fine and if you
get told hey yeah you're the thing you
wrote it was pretty dumb then you go
okay
lesson learned maybe that was a bad idea
you know I know some of the ideas that
you let out of your head echo Charles to
me sometimes times they take some abuse
yes sir
well actually I mean in a way that's
kind of what I was thinking when you're
saying that I was like yeah it's a sin
to come out but like about what if it's
like because in my mind it has like a
non-rigid approval process seems saying
so echo you know it comes expand which I
don't ask you to do very often and I may
never ask you again like I said
non-rigid so you know you come up with
an idea you get reminded of something or
whatever and then you're like oh yeah
that'd be cool if I did this and then it
hits like a first the first small
road-blocking like okay that's not a
good idea like kind of the realism of
the world kind of introduces itself an
idea kind of fizzles and then but what
if it passes that you know in your
little mind or whatever right my keys my
little mind and he comes and and it
actually like it has like getting aa
city feeling like maybe you tell you why
I forgot it that sounds like a no not
even we're not even there I just like
the third layer whatever the second
layer is kind of like you kind of think
of all the the criteria and all the
elements of the world that that need to
fit in place for this to be a good idea
it's like ah yeah it's kind of clicking
you know you can kind of see the success
you know in the future kind in your head
then okay that's another layer okay it
passes that most of the ideas to be
honest don't even pass that yeah so you
tell me about this because you have a
Bank of ideas you know videos that you
started for the most part right started
this video and you say you have a bank
of them and some of them you go you go
back to him you say you know that was a
pretty good idea but it failed here or
sometimes you said I'm gonna carry
through with this idea yeah and yeah
exactly yeah and there's a lot of those
little craters like now you could I
could look at them and be like okay that
was a good idea for that time but if I
finish this now I won't land now that'd
be like everyone be like that's kind of
old-school concept kind of thing and
yeah it's a whole spectrum of things
there's probably more videos and stuff
like that then in that Bank so I guess I
guess maybe you don't need you maybe if
you don't produce like you don't have to
finish the thing but you gotta at least
get it out there into the world I don't
know I think you kind of gotta finish
well I think you're correct at the end
of the day as long as it gets like
through those however many layers yeah
I'm sure we all have different layers of
approval in our own head but then as
long as it passes kind of that that one
standard layer that it needs to pass you
know you know the one where you're like
you know what at the end of the day you
you you stop thinking about it but
before you stop thinking about it you
came to the decision okay that is in
fact a good idea maybe not a level five
good idea but even like a level through
a doable level three
you know once it gets to that level and
then you don't do it Dan yes I agree
percent it's a sin interesting and then
that's interesting how you're like um
even if it ends up not being a good idea
and it gets judgment by the world or
whatever like the fact that it's out
like that is the reason it's true it's
that's true for everything that's true
for your own face really like what like
you got in the world everyone's gonna
look at what you got what you have to
give to the world and they're gonna
evaluate it that's that just the way it
goes if people don't like your nose then
they don't like your nose what should
you not have been born I don't think so
but nonetheless yeah fatica ly shaking
your head over there Dave well I think
something you said earlier it really
doesn't have anything to do with whether
or not you produce this for the world to
consume it if you got an idea in your
head there's something in the night and
look I know what it feels like to have
ideas in your head you have to get that
thing out whether anybody else your
brain your body actually needs it that
like exercise that is a thing that you
need to do and if you share it with
somebody that really has nothing to do
with the part where you need to get that
thing out of your head you got to
squeeze your brain and get something out
and you know what if it goes to someone
else that's awesome but that's like
saying hey you know what I don't need to
workout today or I don't need to rest it
or I don't need to eat healthy too if
you got something in your head that's an
idea you have to exercise your brain to
get that thing out what does where it
goes next you can talk about it all day
but yeah any time you don't do that as
you said it might be an excuse they're
all excuses yeah yeah you know you said
squeezing your brain and and then echo
repeated it because I've had separate
conversations with both of you guys
about squeezing right yeah because the
the the ideas they're in there but they
do sometimes you need to squeeze your
brain to get them to come out you got to
put a little work in yeah somebody's got
to put a lot of work yeah that's the
counter to the common you know I was an
advocate of this by the way or if it's
like hey if it's not coming to you then
it's just not it's time yeah you know
you're just not ready for it quite yet
you know kind of thing and and my
solution to quote writer's block
yeah just keep writing just write write
down yep oak you can't figure out that
idea cold right around it and you'll
figure it out yeah we'll tension there
so we get to the code here's the code
one I will take care of my physical
health by exercising eating properly and
getting the rest I need to recover and
rebuild I will take care of my physical
surroundings keeping them in order does
it strike anyone as strange to start
with the physical no sir I have a real
easy answer for anyone that says well
you know your your brain is paramount if
your body's not working your brain isn't
so number one thing take care of your
physical health too I will develop
myself meant
by reading writing drawing building
creating and engaging in other
activities that sharpen and expand my
mind 3 I will not waste time time is
precious
4 I will not waste money and I will make
prudent financial decisions money is
hard to earn 5 I will set goals that I
will strive toward 6
I will excel in my job because work is
integral to life 7 I will be humble and
not allow my ego to negatively impact my
decisions 8 I will control my emotions
and not allow my emotions to negatively
impact my decisions 9 I will put others
before myself
I will help other people and protect
those that cannot protect themselves I
will take care of my friends and family
and treat other people with respect 10 I
will be ready to protect my friends and
family my gear will be ready I will
train and prepare to defend myself and
others it's the code and I just kind of
well I I guess I kind of covered here
look that it says then it says this this
code is not perfectly suited to everyone
but it is not unalterable you can modify
it if needed customize it for you and
your life while it isn't perfect it's a
good place to start and while we may
never be able to live up to this code we
will be better for having tried now I
don't I have a hard time conceiving of
someone that would look at any of these
things in the code and be like yeah I
don't agree with that one is there
anything that you can say well don't
know about that yeah no that doesn't
mean it has to be exactly like this and
your code can be what you want it to be
but there's nothing in here you would
look at and go humility doesn't apply to
me and actually if you're thinking that
red flag
red-flag we are actually we started
talking about this part of it we're on a
plane I think we're actually you may be
headed to Australia we're sitting
together on a plane and we're talking
about hey we need to write the code
itself as Adam you know we're talking
about the warrior kid code and it came
from this idea what you were talking
about before which was if we don't if
we're not on the path we just become
whatever we've become but that's not how
it has to be it doesn't that is not your
feet are not predestined to just become
whatever you can actually control in a
lot of ways what you become and what
path you get on but you need to you need
to know how to do that you need a code
to tell you how to do that this is less
about doing the specific thing that
we're talking about and more about
having a code that defines who you are
so you are on some path yeah because if
you're not on some path and your path is
different than your path and difference
in my path but if you're not on a path
you are destined to become whatever yeah
and that that is not okay yeah and from
a decentralized command perspective look
my troops in the field can make a
decision on what they're gonna do based
on the overall commander's intent but we
go through life with nope not
understanding our own commanders intent
of our life so if you take this and you
need to make decisions about your life
this just gives you the broad framework
to say you know what I'm not gonna I
should I should I should I look at
another Netflix show right now or should
I go and work good it showed you
something productive well I will not
waste time time is precious okay I I
know what decision to make there hey I
want to buy this frivolous you know
whatever new what do you buy a gold
chain new gold chain right you could now
you could say well you know I really
want it and it looks really cool or
whatever and then you say you know what
I will not waste money and I will make
prudent financial decisions yeah I don't
need the gold chain like there's a
understanding your own commanders intent
and and having that as a framework to
make your decisions on allows you to
make good decisions all the time should
I have this doughnut no sir
right I mean I'm gonna take care of my
physical health should I
should I drink this whiskey well it's
debatable but Yemen
I dig it wait wait wait what was that
answer it's debatable
I'm just is that kind of like you know
when you're flying a plane like your
instruments you're avoiding the question
HECO Charles what are we drinking this
time connection between me flying an
airplane in the plants ok whisky up you
know maybe if you're building
cohesiveness within a team I'm sure you
know it could apply you seem sane or
let's say you're a writer which I'm not
by the way so this hypothetical and you
do it to facilitate your creative
process I would question that
yeah very sternly sure I would say that
that's not gonna help you I don't know I
say you might want to check your code
wait who's the who's the writer he's
like a prolific Oh like super famous
writer who just drink whiskey all the
time or something noticed anyway yeah I
think it was Hemingway I don't know if
someone talks I don't think that's
actually I think people are gonna push
back those brains out with a shocker
let's lay it let's lay off but
everyone's path is different the people
are gonna push back the hardest are the
people that are drinking booze and the
reality is is there's there's actually a
code cache you can ask yourself should I
be doing this right now yeah yeah I dig
it man
that's the point I understand going on
like I said like I said in the book
while we may never live up to this code
we will be better for having tried we
will get stronger faster smarter we will
build a better career
we'll be better mothers fathers husbands
wives daughters and sons we will be
healthier our lives will be better and
we will make the lives of those around
us better pretty straightforward
yeah again you could look at that code
and say well you know you should have
said this or you should have said that
it's like mmm look at them and if you
feel like there's something that needs
to be added cool add to your code if
there's something that you just
vehemently disagree with cool subtract
but set yourself up set yourself up with
a commander's
ten set yourself up with a code that you
can follow that can guide your
decision-making process and by the way
when you set it up for yourself why not
share it with your family so your family
can kind of all be moving in the same
direction you and I've interacted with
with literally thousands and thousands
of people just in the last year
thousands of people have interacted and
not everyone is healthy not everyone's
doing the right thing not everyone is on
the path but it's almost universal that
people want to be that they want to be
and this is what allows them to realize
I can actually control that fate just a
little bit more and a thousand people
that they all want their lives to be
better they all want their family's
lives to be better there's just this
crazy idea that there was something that
seemed as simple as that there what was
missing was just the recognition of how
to start to do that it wasn't to try to
convince people that they should it was
more to explain people how they can and
and closing that gap between what they
want and what they are was that there
was something in the middle was telling
them how to do it or how to even think
about how to do it you're talking about
your own commanders intent that's a
really powerful way to describe what
you're doing is like what is your own
commanders intent for yourself it was
never a question two people want their
lives almost everybody wants their lives
to be better and healthier and the
people around them better it was not
having that understanding your own mind
what you need to do for yourself to do
that yeah and and you probably heard me
talk about the the German German you
know decentralized command zero talking
about decentralized command about
Americans briefs and how we have you
know 120 slides in a brief and then the
last slide is the commander's intent
that says this is what I really want
done and the German generals saying the
the commander's intent shouldn't be an
addendum to all those different slides
it should replace them and so anything
you can say about hey you know we could
write a book about how to be healthy
right like here's what you need to do
here's your workout all those things you
can write all that stuff down but the
most important thing is hey you need to
make decisions
lean towards good health that's you can
replace every exercise book and every
self-help book with the underlying
personal commander's intent of what
you're trying to do and it'll solve many
many of your problems yeah for sure and
that goes with financial that goes with
your work all those things if you're
going to work with the attitude of like
hey I'm gonna do a good job that's money
just think of that commander's intent
I'm gonna do a good I'm gonna be a good
I'm gonna do a good job at my work
that's that's my goal you know I was
talking about this on Jocko life a lot
not a lot but I think one or two of the
shows this came up where I got to
talking about when I got to the SEAL
Teams one of the things that just
changed my life and made everything go
so well was this idea and the idea was
as a 19 year old I had this idea in my
head and the idea was I want to be a
good seal just I want to be a good seal
that's what that's what I want to do and
then every decision that I'm making is
is this gonna make me a good seal and as
soon as I had that as my underlying kind
of decision-making process I started
moving in a direction and so lucky is
very lucky for me because otherwise I
got all this energy as a young kid you
know I was a really horrible young kid I
was crazy and I'd gotten all kinds of
trouble and caused all kinds of trouble
and the minute I took all that energy
and turned it to one thing I want to be
a good seal and it took me some time to
figure out what a good seal wasn't I
made some errors along the way for sure
but when I would when I was trying to be
a good seal and then all of a sudden I
did something that was wrong and it was
making me not a good seal I could just
correct it because I was a guy this
doesn't seem like this is being a good
seal so you apply that to all these
different elements of your life to your
physical health to your mental health to
not procrastinating to beat you know
being a good worker to taking care of
your family to being prepared and we
wrote this by the way way before
you know kovat 19 right and now all of a
sudden people man I wish I was a little
bit more prepared yes yes you should be
prepared so to get better continue along
with the book and to do that we must
strive we must strive to be better in
the things that matter the code sets a
standard the highest possible standard
the highest possible standard reveals
and delineates the paths we must follow
and then it gets into what is the path
the path is how you become what you want
to be who you want to be and what the
world needs you to be it is how you
reach your potential it is the path of
discipline that leads to freedom the
path is a war against weakness so it
leads to strength it's a war against
ignorance so it leads to knowledge a war
against confusion so it delivers
understanding that is the path of life
and I've got a nasty because I always
talk about the path we always talk about
the path Eko Charles yes sir in fact we
all closed many of the podcast we talked
about hey how do we stay on the path how
do we get on the path yes sir and of
course people sometimes ask what is that
what is the path here you go that's what
this section is for and some of those
you know like it's direct quotes talking
about the path but the path is your life
and it continues on the path is your
life and so the path is different for
everyone
it's your goals your dreams what you
want to become the path is yours
but at the same time much of the path is
the same for everyone the path is how
you strive to become an eminently
qualified human and then it gets into
how do I find the path what does that
look like some sense in here saying now
the path is different for everyone
hmm finding the path isn't as hard as
you think some of it is clearly defined
in the code the rest of the path comes
from simple questions you can ask
yourself
do you care about who do you want to be
what matters most to you what are the
most important things in your life who
are the most important people in your
life and what do they need from you
answer those questions then write down
what you need to do to achieve them
those things that you need to do that
you are supposed to do that you know you
must do those things are the path the
path is in your head waiting for you to
follow it
once again it's it's funny that when we
talk about the path even though people
like what's the path everyone kind of
knows what it is like like you know many
people have come up to me little have
been on the path for like two years now
we never define the path but they know
what the path is I've been on the
bathroom I've been on the path you know
when when I used to me now I when I used
to meet people to come up to me and
they'd say hey man it's really good to
meet you I feel like how long you been
on the path for and this is something
that had never been defined never said
the path was this this this and this but
they knew what the path was yeah it's in
their head they know you were talking
about you said if you don't do this it's
a mortal sin
he's the mortal sin you said earlier the
path is what the world needs you to be
that's the mortal sin by not being on
the path is that you are failing the
world the world needs you to be this
that's the mortal sin of not doing
whatever this thing is you need to do
whatever that path is not being on the
path is that's what the world needs you
to be
I think that's legit
next section how do I stay on the path
once you see the path you must begin to
walk down it this can be the most
difficult part of the journey to break
free of the gravitational pull of
weakness habit and fear the
gravitational pull of weakness habit and
fear those are some strong gravitational
poles yes the best way to start is to
start don't hesitate don't wait don't
analyze or plan or research just start
now once you begin down the path you
will soon realize it is not an easy path
the path is fraught with obstacles and
distractions laziness ego weakness and
immediate gratification will try to pull
you off the path every day you must
fight them you will even have to fight
people who don't want you on the path
but you can fight then you can win what
is it about people that don't want you
on the path you know what I'm saying
it's that self reflection right thing
where you know how millions of examples
but you know the kind where you see
someone like you see someone like
working hard and it's like man you kind
of know in the back your head straight
up consciously though like I should be
working harder and that kind of like
demonstrates it for it's like a reminder
of how hard you could be working but
you're not I don't like that feeling so
hey if you just stopped working hard I
wouldn't have to like do anything hard
and I could actually feel better you
know it's like that kind of kind of
situation I think this happened in
Australia at the muster we would do our
workouts so before the muster we're like
running dry rehearsals of the of the pts
the early morning pts and so we'd be out
there for 4:30 in the morning and people
would walk by and it was interesting
it's interesting because it'd be you
know it's time
people some people coming home from the
pub's right it's four o'clock in the
morning right we're seeing people they
got their they got their drank on and so
but it's interesting how some people
would say some people are just would
just be negative you know well you don't
want you what are you doing you know
there and and what you can just feel it
coming out of their system they just
feel guilty and horrible yeah yeah it's
not it's a lot less about you than it is
about them those gravitational forces of
weakness and fear man they like company
they like other people some of them
saying they they see you break it free
in those gravitational forces they don't
like that then it's better for them if
you stay down there with them because
that forces them to start to reconcile
their own weakness and their own fear
and their own gravitational pulls it's
putting in the wrong direction and
that's what you're fighting against as
I'm seeing you break and free from that
and that's gonna be a problem for them
yes wish when those people are like
close to you with you know I guess you
know I see it
I understand but man it's kind of been
worse when they're close to you for them
you see them saying like what if your
what a drinking buddy is now like doing
something else and he's not drink he's
not drinking it oh man you know yeah
just come and have a beer with me come
on
yeah that's wrong with you yeah yeah man
well what happened let's go have some
fun come on yeah forget about this path
stuff but he's talking about what are
you doing improving yourself yeah it's
we're that used to really I'm sure you
saw this in the Marine Corps but well
maybe you did then the SEAL Teams you'd
see someone trying to step up and you
see other people trying to hack away
totally nasty yeah worst thing ever is
it it you know how like when you're
close to someone you kind of have this
kind of picture of them you know like
this um like this just idea of who they
are right and then what's so one they
and then you kind of in a way you kind
of get used to it or get comfortable
with it like in the relationship and all
that someone they change you kind of
throw off the relationship a little bit
like it's like oh my whole image of you
is like changing now I'm uncomfortable
it feels like that too sometimes you
know like wait you know if you just
especially if they make a quick like
drastic change
the idea like manna there's a little
more distance yeah because it makes it
feel uncomfortable in that way as well
you know like because it's like that
almost like a like a social comfort zone
you know where it's like they're
different it's almost like oh the friend
that I know even though you're better
technically the friend that I've come to
know and love the distance is different
yeah yeah it's not there anymore you
know
the the when Seth stone was I had this
idea in his head that he wanted to go to
Princeton wanted to go underground at
Princeton and so he started you know
he's an active duty in the SEAL Teams
and there's no program that sends you to
Princeton and he he says to me he's like
hey no I'm thinking about trying to go
to Princeton like and I guess there was
some program that might have been in the
process of being created or whatever but
it wasn't a real thing yet and I said I
said bro that's that's yeah that'll be
awesome man that'll be awesome
I mean you'll be degree from freakin
Princeton right and he comes back to me
a few days later and we weren't ain't
asking a bruiser at this time he says
yeah I'm not sure if I should really go
and I said why not man he's like well
some of the other officers I've talked
to said that it's not a good idea I knew
it could mess up my timing in my career
and stuff and I said bro
that is just this absolute jealousy and
from Prince yeah and you know the thing
is Seth had such a big heart you know
and he was so loyal like even when he
asked guys he kind of took it at face
value all they're looking out for me and
I said bro these guys are jealous you
should absolutely apply and he did and
he went and yeah obviously I did that's
the that's the thing though is the
beauty about being off the path and you
get on the path there's a lot of people
on the path so whatever you're losing
whatever those friends are those grab
that you forget them quickly because
there's a lot of people on the path that
are gonna replace them immediately
getting on the path fear whatever you're
breaking free from all those people
gonna try to pull you down those people
fade and almost immediately when you get
on the path because the satisfaction of
being on the path with other people that
are on the path
dude that is a way more powerful
gravitational force than the fear of
letting your friends down to say hey
just come hang out with me complaints
video games or whatever people do today
I'm beat yeah and that's not to mention
the people that actually come with you
even a little bit you know how like um I
think it's Jordan Peterson saying like
you to find out who your friends are
see who like is happy with your success
or something along those lines right and
that's kind of what it does to where you
know like the old drinking buddy some of
them will be like all hating on these
like oh he's too good for us now you
know matter whatever but then every once
in a while like you'll get one be like
hey wait what are you doing we're here
let me get some you know let me try that
let me come with you
you know wherever you know um did you
just do whatever um so then that'll
differentiate and that'll separate and
identify kind of like who's your
quote-unquote real friends as well yeah
and if you see your friends becoming
successful and you start feeling that
little twinge of you don't you want to
bring them down yeah you're doing that
guy then don't let that happen
continue on every moment you are alive
is made of choices you get to make
little tiny choices that alone mean
nothing but when combined together mean
everything you have to make the right
choices the hard choices you have to
deny immediate gratification and push
back against weakness you must impose
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things that is how you stay on the path
we must stay on the path if we are to
become an eminently qualified human
being but what does this Emily qualified
human look like what are the attributes
of this person and intimately qualified
human is a person who has achieved
mastery in every facet of life this
person has reached their full potential
in every measurable way this person
lives the code but in order for us to
live the code we need to clearly define
its parts so that we can evaluate our
progress every day we need an evaluation
system to grade ourselves as we attempt
to follow the code and it should be hard
the ball
must be set high it should be near
impossible but just in striving we will
become better and we must implement
discipline we must aim to implement
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things it is the only way there are
countless aspects of life each with its
varying level of importance but what are
the most important what aspects of life
should be focused where should the
pursuit of excellence be concentrated
it's easy to say that everyone's life is
different and that is impossible to
quantify categories that are the most
important but that isn't true there are
some things in life which should be
universally placed in the forefront of
our efforts as human beings to that end
there are the most critical parts of
being an eminently qualified human and
how they should be measured this is how
we set the standard this is the code
evaluation and so now we get into this
evaluation and this is where we tie into
well this is where it all stem from this
Marine Corps evaluation which sets the
insane and Annika Li unachievable goals
and I would I would tell you that even
someone that got 5 O's and categories
you could you could dig those down a
little bit I got five of those in
categories I can tell you I hadn't that
stand yeah not happening so the first
category is health since our physical
bodies are the support mechanisms for
our brains physical fitness and health
are paramount to our existence to be
able to engage in the critical critical
aspects of life our bodies need to be
able to endure the demands we place on
it we need to exercise be well rested
and well nourished to reach optimal
health
on top of cardiovascular health a person
must be strong fast agile flexible and
mobile to be each of those things you
have to engage in activities that
positively impact all of them what we
put into our bodies and how we effective
how effectively we rest our bodies play
an equally important role
in ensuring we can perform at the
highest level you can't reach your
potential if you aren't healthy so this
is what you're grading yourself on this
is the evaluation this is how you're
grading yourself the number one thing
that you're grading is health
it starts with physical fitness one
point one physical fitness being
physically fit allows you to perform
daily functions from working to playing
with your kids to moving things around
the house all while wall avoiding injury
having an effective fitness routine when
you're young sets the foundation for
being fit later in life maintaining your
physical fitness becomes more critical
as you get older this is a basic daily
necessity and then it talks about
one-point-two sleep and rest brain and
body recovery is rooted in sleep a
scientific studies on the effects of
sleep continue to mount it's becoming
more and more evident that you must
consistently get your required amount of
sleep in order to cognitively perform on
the highest levels sleeping too little
or too much have dramatic negative
effects on your body and ability to
perform establish the amount of sleep
you need and prioritize accordingly yeah
I've had to point people back to the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
when they're like what time are you
waking up what time do you go to bed
what's wrong with you you're killing
yourself you're so unhealthy no no some
people need different amounts of sleep
and if you need sleep you need to get
sleep yeah and then the next part of
health is diet and nutrition there's no
part of you your diet does not effect
the fuel for your body determines how
you look feel and function determines
how it looks feels and functions
knowledge and implementation of what
constitutes a healthy diet is imperative
and will make the difference between
maximum performance and substandard
performance so there you have it yeah
that's straight for that right there is
health
the next thing we go into is called
purse 2.0 personal development personal
development much like our bodies we need
to nourish and grow are much like how we
need to nourish and grow our bodies our
brains and personal behaviors need the
same attention our brains need
activities like reading writing building
creative pursuits and other actions that
promote intellectual health we also need
to train ourselves to improve how we
deal with the challenges in our personal
world making the best use of our limited
time and money and setting goals all
contribute to personal development so
this is one of those things work you
know if you don't if you're not grading
and that's the point of this evaluation
if you don't grade if someone doesn't
show you like when I was a young seal
and I thought I was doing a good job
with tactics and then they show me what
it says to be a tactical 5.0 I'm not
even close you know so how often do we
think about from a personal development
perspective that we're actually doing an
outstanding job
we don't even most people don't even
know what that even remotely looks like
so then we talk about intellectual
fitness while carried in the chasis of
the body the mind is supreme it is us it
needs to be protected nourished and
trained you exercise the brain and make
it more capable by reading writing
studying and learning new things you
need to develop an areas you don't
always that don't always fit into your
normal routine even if your job or
responsibilities don't demand it
cultivate something artistic like music
writing or singing do things you're not
good at and try activities that make you
uncomfortable they promote creativity
and intellectual growth remember how
just psycho we go whenever you and I
talk about the the the fact the creative
aspect of combat and war and how much
the Marine Corps talks about this
creative nature yeah creative nature
needs to be developed yeah
the idea of intellectual fitness is
being a thing that that you have to
force yourself to do things you're not
good at to exercise your own brain it's
easy to think about that in the physical
term oh I want to get better at
something I'll do this physical exercise
I will run or I will lift weights or
whatever I'll stretch if I'm not good at
I don't have good flexibility I can fix
that by stretching the intellectual
piece is especially it working people at
the in the grinder and the routine and
they just get stuck in this day to day
thing of what they're doing is your
brain needs you to force it to do things
that's not good at to get better and
it's not that you become a master
pianist or a brilliant musician is that
your brain gets better and smarter and
stronger and you can do so many other
things better by doing that the
intellectual fitness piece is how your
brain grows which it has to do every day
I don't I can never remember being told
to think about how you were growing a
brand every day I did not have that
growing up I nobody told me that I
didn't think about that and it never
occurred to me that this is something
that I everyday need to think about how
I'm doing it gives you and I I would say
people are now kind of discovering like
they'll tell like hey when you're over
60 you should try and learn an
instrument or try and learn a new
language because it makes your brain
your brain is like your body needs work
yeah he's exercise and not to mention
just how look the mind is the ultimate
weapon I was just telling my son that
the other day you know because he all he
wants to do is what Jack steel right
train like that's it I said hey man
that's awesome I get it but you better
you better sharpen that others down
another tool you got to cuz that's the
ultimate weapon yeah and you can feel it
I can oh yeah like like I can feel it
when I'm when I'm on point when I'm
doing a bunch of work with a bunch of
clients or I'm digging deep with you
know writing something or going through
you know when I'm when I'm preparing for
a podcast I can feei
feel the the foundation getting stronger
you know I feel my own mental foundation
getting stronger because I have better
understanding and connecting the Datsun
and following the thread and figuring
out where things connect and that's just
powerful you get a lot of exercise so to
speak collaborator of your brain just by
talking to so many people Oh like yeah I
mean you ever been in a situation where
you didn't talk to anyone for like a
week
not anyone at all but like you've been
pretty Weatherby stayed in your house or
whatever maybe just me but I don't let's
say I don't have many social
interactions we'll say for like a little
extended period of time
when you jump back into social
situations you feel kind of awkward you
know so it's same thing as if like you
stopped lifting for a while then you try
to get underneath that weight again and
you're like oh this is a little heavier
than I then I remember it being you know
yeah you know when Jordan Peterson kind
of hit the scene and people with people
were talking about about Jordan and
they'd say man he gives these incredible
answers right and and I'd be like yeah
definitely and then I'd say go watch his
lecture from 1987 when he's a professor
at Harvard he's given that answer that
you know someone asks him yeah whatever
whatever they're gonna ask him he's he's
actually given that answer and fought
through it at a deep level that he's
gonna give you be able to give that
answer and it's gonna sound amazing
because he's prepared that answer at
that moment for 30 years but here's the
thing that having that base is what
allows you to riff when the time comes
it allows you to make that little
adjustment to that individual person so
the more training you get the more
exercise you get the better you're gonna
be I mean you know you also see it with
like like politicians if you see a
politician and someone catches them with
them where they don't really haven't
fought through that answer before
depending on their intellectual
yes sometimes they can figure out a way
around it but sometimes they're just
looking dumped you know what I'm saying
because they're just they just don't
know how to do it
mm-hmm and you can see a good a good
politician they get asked something that
catches them off guard and they're able
to handle it in a good positive way you
know like like hey oh you know what
that's it that's you know when you make
them you know they have their answer
they have a way of doing it they have a
way of contemplating what's going on in
real time because they're used to doing
it and you know you know Dave this is
kind of our life not the political side
but working with companies and going in
and having people ask us questions and
you know we're gonna score 94% I've
heard that question or a very close
similar question that and then 6% it's
like oh this person has a unique problem
that's that's just their problem how do
we apply our leadership principles to
that problem that they're having and the
more that the stronger your foundation
is the easier it is to say hell yeah
here's what you're experiencing I get it
I understand what you're trying to say
and here's a way to approach that
intellectual fitness to point to time
management there's no more valuable
resource in life than time and is
limited in quantity no one knows how
much time they have so you have to
maximize all of it all of it and yet
people waste their most precious
resource every day how well you manage
your time determines how productive you
are next one financial management like
time money is precious resource so avoid
wasting money on anything that is a
productive track which you spent money
on what you saved and what you invested
if you are disciplined with your money
you will have more of it to spend on
things you want and things you need
what's the criticism that says you know
and jockle it seems like you're awfully
focused on money here right there're
criticism that's gonna come my way
that's gonna be leveled at me that you
should be disciplined with your money
yeah
yeah I think the the reason where this
that this leaves a mark where it's
something that I think people need to
pay attention to is because when I
people that I've known throughout my
entire life when you look at what
problems they have like what is causing
their ankhs to what is causing the the
problems in their life there's a large
percentage of those problems that are
financial problems for sure and if you
don't think about it and you know if
you're gonna talk to if you're gonna
have a code and you're 18 years old look
you're not gonna start thinking of many
professions say that you're not many
people don't start thinking about money
when they're 18 they don't start
thinking about their finance with you
know what their finances when you're 20
years old do I have enough money for
Saturday night cool made it yeah you
know and then they'll go through the
week and then they try and scrape
together a little bit more money and
then in the same question do I have
enough money for Saturday night mmm cool
made it and the only time they adjust is
if they didn't have enough money for
Saturday night and then they go go I've
got to need to work some more hours so
they work a little bit more hours so
they have enough money for Saturday
night not the way to go through life
though in most people that get on the
path they're not jumping on the past so
they can end up with a Ferrari like
that's not the path that they're on this
idea of financial management and
recognizing that this is a price this is
a precious resource that everybody needs
to fulfill whatever is you want if you
want to take music lessons you want to
put your kids through piano that that's
gonna cost a little bit of money and
this idea of financial management is
really the recognition of that whether
you want to admit it or not or whether
you like it or not this is a resource
that is hard to come by it's hard to
come by and it's going to influence your
life that doesn't say your goal should
be to be rich that's not what this s and
that's not even really the point but
this is a resource that is going to
impact your life for your entire life
for you for the people around you and
what it means is that you need to
acknowledge that you need to make
decisions that impact that
so you can have as much of that resource
as possible to do the most good with
that resource when it matters and there
is very few things in the world that you
can do where money does not influence it
for better for worse and you just when
you were talking about what do people
think about when they're 20 you're
talking to every 20 year-old that's out
there right now I mean we can all relate
to that idea of where am I thinking how
far down the road am I thinking that is
not a path that is not the way to go
through life this is a resource that
people need to live the life they want
it doesn't mean you have to be rich it
doesn't mean you have to drive fast cars
and have a nice house it means you have
to have this resource to help the people
around you do the things they need and
if you don't think about that you're not
gonna have it when you need it yeah if
you don't put the goal in place you're
gonna always be looking to Saturday
night yep or whatever that you know
equivalent is in your life which is do I
have enough money to pay the rent do you
know when you're do I have enough money
to feed the kids do I have enough money
for the car payment whatever those
things are yeah you don't have to end up
there no you don't and if there's a
massive disruption like what we're going
through right now if you're on the path
you can deal with that better you can
respond to that better you can take care
of your family better this is about
recognizing that this resource it
impacts your life
and it will forever yeah I guess anybody
that would say ëwell money's not
important that's it's it's tough to
convince me of that
because if even if you're saying hey you
know what I'm gonna live in a van down
by the river you you need to give me gas
for the van yeah and that means you're
gonna have to do something to get money
for gas for the van you know that's the
way it is so you can even and part of
financial management is setting your
expenditures at a point where you can
handle you know like I forget whatever
podcast we talked about financial
management I'm like oh yeah yeah here's
what you do spend less than you make
just start with that spend less than you
make cool yeah that's gonna put you in a
great place in life you know you don't
need the brand-new car off
a lot you don't need that echo Charles I
yeah I understand
well the living in the van thing to
which I'm not saying no one thinks about
this or whatever but like you need much
okay so even your safety right you know
like medical or whatever like if you
break your leg or get some infection or
something living in the van yeah bro
you can be in bad shape compared to you
know if you if you're kind of on the
path there and you're like okay medical
no problem I got insurance or I can pay
for it or whatever you know however you
sort yourself out in that way but yeah
if your local money doesn't mean
anything so I make zero money I'm gonna
live off the land or whatever yeah bruh
unless you're like yeah whatever you're
trained in medical stuff you jammed up
you getting an infection or something
like this yep what about also what about
when you can't take care of your family
oh that's a whole nother ballgame yeah
you know and all of a sudden you go hey
you know what if I'm if I'm sick or
whatever I'll just suck it up and but
what if your kids get sick like well
then what are we gonna do yeah
that's why financial management is
important and if you're not paying
attention to it if you don't have a
clearly defined goal if you don't have
an underlying commander's intent of how
you're gonna live financially you're
gonna be caught in a hamster wheel that
never ends of chasing chasing that dime
you know the people that pay more here's
what here's what here's the weird
dichotomy if I'm a person that don't
doesn't care about money and I'm like
yeah you know money's not important to
me I'm gonna be chasing that dollar for
the rest of my life versus someone that
says you know what money is important
I'm gonna figure out how to take it and
keep it and and grow it that person will
end up not having concerned about money
not having any concerns about money
whereas the person that doesn't care
about money doesn't think it's a big
deal and doesn't want to worry about it
they're gonna be worried about it
forever
so there you go yeah it's kind of like
that one where people people someone
someone asked us I don't really want to
fight so why should I learn jujitsu and
I said if you don't want to fight you
are the number one person that should
learn jujitsu so if you're out there
thinking I don't really care about money
you're the
were one person that should care about
money yeah you can set yourself up for
freedom or you can be a slave
next personal goals you have to know
your objectives you have to know what
your objectives are to put meaning
around the things you are doing set
physical goals like running a 5k or
deadlifting 8,000 pounds set
intellectual goals like learning a
language or pursuing a degree set goals
for diet sleep time money man time and
money management evaluate every day if
your goals need to change and if you
move closer to them track major
milestones for school work competitions
setting and achieving goals is a
critical human pursuit make your goals
hard to achieve when you achieve them
they will have more meaning pretty
straightforward
next up this is the next section that
you are grading yourself in Section
three professional develop development
being good at your job allows you to
provide financially for you and your
family set an example for your children
and achieve long term objectives your
professional success is key to your
personal success performance three point
one performance being secure in your
position at work provide stability
minimize the risk of losing your job and
the means to support yourself or your
family by performing well get better at
your job each day and see take seek and
take feedback from others when there is
an opportunity find ways to actively
support others and improve your table
okay so now we'll go down the same path
the path of hey man well I'm not going
through life just to work that's not my
thing I'm not gonna focus on work okay
so that's what you're gonna do you're
not gonna focus on work so for the rest
of your 40 years of working as a human
from 20 to 60
you're not gonna focus on that thing
guess what you're not gonna progress
you're always gonna be at the bottom of
the chain of command you're gonna have
little to no control over your fate and
I was just talking about that with a
client right before we came here the in
the Navy I couldn't give anyone a pay
raise I mean I could get them promoted
it takes two or three years whatever I
can't give someone a pay raise the way
you pay people is you give them control
over their own nest
so when you work hard you end up with
control over your destiny I'll tell you
what man I was in the military for 20
years I would say 15 of those years I
had almost complete unmitigated control
over my own destiny yeah as crazy as
that sounds like as crazy as that sounds
15 years I'm talking day by day like you
know maybe pawn point maybe one hour of
a day you know last week I had a guy
that was like here you need to get this
done I was like hey Roger that and I
didn't have control over my own destiny
the other 90% of the time I was I had
things set up in a way that I control my
own destiny when I remember I was one of
the few kids growing up in my circle of
friends at school that one of them
during the military most people didn't
and you know the common thing was um I
don't want people tell me what to do you
know I don't want to be you know getting
yelled at by people or you know outrank
me whatever that idea was of what the
military was like and I didn't really
know what the military is like I'm just
kind of enamored by it and I actually
sort of thought there would be some
yelling involved and have you told what
to do there aren't a lot of jobs in the
world where you don't work for somebody
and what you describe even in the
military which people think is like the
most rigid hierarchy bro the amount of
autonomy that I had when I was the
squadron commander of the world's only
f-35 squadron in the world I could do
almost anything I could do almost
anything yes and I have a boss of course
did I have metric had to meet of course
just like in almost every other job in
the world I answered to somebody but the
the tool that gave me all that autonomy
was years and years and years of years
of actually doing my job well and the
freedom that being good at your work
gives you down the road you could be in
the military to any rank if you're
really good at your job you know you get
you get freedom you get autonomy you get
a little control over your life and
everybody wants that when we get asked
we get asked all the time people talk
about problems that have at work and the
two simplest ways to get through what
the problems are one is typically
connected to relationships hey how's
your relationship with this person
whatever problem you're having
and the other one is how good are you at
your job because most people that are
really good at their job don't have a
lot of problems at work they just don't
and it's the ones that have I have
friction with my boss or my leadership
er and they talk about all these
problems oftentimes the thing they can
do to get make it most of those problems
go away it's just do a better job
because if you don't matter job your
boss is gonna stop bugging you your
peers are gonna stop bugging your
subordinate or to stop giving you a hard
time and so this idea of performance
that's the best thing you could do
whether you're working for the man or
for the sergeant that gives you the most
amount of freedom and self control over
your life is just be good at work when I
was writing leadership strategy and
tactics that was a very in-depth review
of my life in my career in a lot of ways
yeah and oh that's one of the things as
I dug down and said why was I was what
did I do to build trust what did I do to
get autonomy what didn't I do to get
ownership what I do to get all those
things knows you know I'm sitting there
squeezing my brain one night I was like
uh uh uh I don't actually know exactly
what I did I worked really hard and did
a good job and when you work really hard
to do a good job people start and and
actually working really hard as just
what I had to do to do a good job yeah
if you can just do a good job you don't
even have to work hard I had to work a
little harder but that idea of
performance and again if there's someone
that's sitting here listening going well
you know I don't like what I do cool do
awesome and awesome out and other
opportunities will open up including
saying hey boss
I really appreciated working here I
think I'm gonna move on to a different
career can I get a letter of
recommendation absolutely you've done
great thank you
boom so but the the other the other
viewpoint would say if you're not into
it you know you don't want to invest a
bunch of time into it okay what are you
gonna do then what are you gonna do yeah
this is your job this is your vocation
go and do it and do it well and you know
what sometimes sometimes it actually
involves just doing what you're told
it's sometimes when you're the new guy
you're brand new and and even if it
doesn't quite make sense you maybe don't
want to do it I don't work sometimes
just do what you're told in the
beginning build a little credibility
don't push back
everything and if that just means just
following orders at the beginning which
is what all brand-new people do they
just kind of following orders we hope
they do well you start to figure things
out a little bit understand what your
bosses intent was and really not just
giving orders he's actually had a larger
purpose but you follow through they get
some credibility you give them more
autonomy and yet does that mean
sometimes you're just gonna get on board
and just do whatever you're asked to do
to make things happen yes it does but
that doesn't last forever
that usually doesn't even lasted very a
long time it actually is a really short
period of time and the best way to get
to that is just just be the guy that's
outperforming everybody else keep your
mouth shut and do good work and very
quickly very quickly you find yourself
with the freedom the autonomy and and
and you get to be in charge sometimes
and you get to make your own decisions
with other folks so this idea of being
good at your job it affects every part
of your life yeah every part of your
yeah and once again if you've got the
miserable job that you hate the best
thing you can do is be automatic invest
do awesome at it because you'll get
promoted out of that job or you'll get
openings to another thing in the world
that will allow you to to do something
that you like which speaking of which
next section advancement in
qualifications figure out what is
required to promote or advance and take
deliberate steps to do so determine what
certifications or qualifications are
required to outperform your competition
then earn them find a meaning in your
job if your job doesn't have meaning
design an exit strategy to move to one
that does a lot of our time will be
spent at work make it matter and hey
this idea of find out what it takes to
promote there are some guys in the teams
that like would go through that little
book and go will I get this qual and
they don't get this quality no I'm ready
for my that's not what I'm talking about
no no no not what I'm talking about but
that is part of performance so do it
with the right with the right context ya
know I mean that's the yeah that I think
you've talked about this a bunch and I
think in the Navy in the Marine Corps
there's a safe I think it's the same
phrase we call them ticket punchers all
right I think it's the same it might be
you know like you know check-in the
block or whatever there's some length
lingo out there but that is not what
this is this isn't I'm a ticket puncher
but there is a little bit like hey do I
want some control what do I need to do
to get little bit around here well you
do this for a while and then there's a
certification that you can be kind of a
master craftsman in your trade or you
get to get a certification where you get
to be an instructor in this in this
capability hey I'd like to know what
that is you learned about it you get
better at it those are two very
different things and you're doing it to
make yourself better make your team
around you better and make make your
world better is a lot different than I'm
gonna you know trick the system and then
whatever just get my ticket puncher
succeed until they don't and when they
don't it's usually pretty bad when you
get kind of highlighted in revealed it's
a ticket puncher things don't usually
end well for those people yeah yeah it's
into the interesting dichotomy that just
kind of showed up on these last two is
if you don't want to care about money
you should care about money if you don't
want to care about your job you should
care about your job and exit comes from
discipline
yeah the freedom comes from
disciplinarian next section 4.0
character and leadership who we are as a
person is perhaps the most defining
quality in our life our character
impacts those around us and the world we
live in and we are in complete control
of it learning humility managing our
egos and leading and mentoring people in
our world are ways we can choose to
develop our character remember you don't
need to be in charge of anyone or
anything to lead everyone has the
ability and the obligation to lead
four-point-one humility this is the most
important quality in a leader ego is the
biggest killer and combat business and
life be honest in your self-assessment
of your own ego and control it if your
ego gets out of control
you will lose watch out for you go
emotional control stifle your emotions
emotion one is emotional but we but not
everyone can control their emotions
we are not effective when we are
emotional we don't have protect
productive conversations send good
emails or mark make smart decisions when
we lose control of our emotions know
your red flags and learn to identify
what emotions start to take over
children struggle controlling their
emotions eminently qualified humans do
not yeah that's who gets upset that's
who gets angry kids little children kids
so if you're not a little child get
control of your emotions how many people
echo Charles have pushed back on
spiteful your emotions right significant
I've heard it all I've heard it if you
do that that's what drives mental health
problems no look I'm not saying don't
have any emotions control them though
yeah how about you act like an adult
yeah there's because well one we did
analyze that or whatever if you call it
an analysis it's not that you're like
bottling them up you're dealing with
them in a in a specific processing or
general way yeah so you you know there's
a difference between how you feel and
how you behave so if you just relate
like however I feel I'm gonna behave
that's like an emotional behavior
emotional decision emotional whatever
but if you run it through like a little
filter whatever that filter is and don't
behave emotionally
it'll help develop your capability to
deal with it you just control your
emotion yeah and it's good character you
know that's that's this section is
character right it's character and
leadership be humble keep control of
your emotions and then the other part of
character is mentoring and charity so
part of your character is to the book
you're helping others having outlets to
provide support to those that need it in
a way that is productive for them set
your best example mentor someone help
set goals for friends and
members and take care of other people I
mean the thing that's so important about
what you said at the beginning is that
this kind of defines who we are but
you're a hundred percent control over
this you are in control over all of this
it doesn't say don't have emotions but
you should never let your emotions
control you you should be in control of
how you react to your emotions and the
difference is and we get this all the
time is hey I had this issue at work and
I try to work it out with this person
and I lost my temper I had that
conversation go how'd that work out the
problem gets solved no it didn't because
I could not I can't tell them don't feel
angry I can't say that don't feel angry
but as you find yourself feeling I'm
there you can actually control how you
respond to that anger and it could be
you just deal with it put in this place
and continue the conversation it could
be that you find a different time
another conversation but the anger is
not in charge of you you were in control
of this I have yet to had an interaction
with someone where they lost their
temper lost control of their emotions
lost control of how they were feeling
and the outcome was good yeah I'm
thinking about I'm thinking about how in
my life like at some point realizing
that this was not a good thing and I was
definitely watching you know leaders
that I had lose their temper and then
just getting to a point where you know
it's agree you're not gonna face me like
I'm not gonna you're not gonna you're
not gonna see that I'm getting
frustrated right okay I'm I'm listening
and if I do show you some frustration
it's gonna be actively trying to show
you that I'm frustrating because I'm
trying to send you the message that like
hey what you're saying right now it
doesn't make sense and you don't see
that and it's so insensible that I'm
actually gonna show you some frustration
so you go Oh chuckles getting frustrated
which I don't see very often
and now I'm feeling it yeah but yeah
that's uh I feel like he's talking of
you not oh actually no I I don't really
get healthy
I don't think you've ever done anything
that's frustrated me actually did you
think of anything oh yeah couple but
what nah they're they're all essentially
jokes okay
just like your ex yeah they're just
jokes like you know even sometimes
you'll you'll be like um
you'll take extreme ownership but it'll
be real obvious that you're blaming me
you know like well maybe I know actually
you know what that's my fault
I should be pressing record on that
thing you know it's up to me you know
like that can stuff but no no yeah those
are just fun yeah those are just good
times yeah because it's gonna be hard to
frustrate me yeah it's gonna be hard to
frustrate me even even on the mats of
justice yeah you know fatigue is fatigue
and emotion kind of yeah it's a feeling
it's a yeah yeah and you can act tired
right you can allow people to see that I
don't even like to do that yeah actually
I learned that was a major lesson I
learned from you dude straight up
directly like don't it I mean I guess
you could oversimplify an input like
don't show weakness or whatever but um
he was like don't don't act tired even
if you are tired like don't act tired
cuz you know that's a common thing
especially in the beginning where you're
like you have a hard round or hard three
rounds or whatever and then after you're
like huh and you flop on it on the mat
or whatever you know and say Kali
you're acting tired right now I know
it's part of the thing and you know what
I even when you come home from work same
thing you know you for what a long day
kind of thing but you don't have to do
that no and there's no real benefit in
doing that like overall maybe some
short-term benefit maybe some feelings
or something but anyway so when did you
say yeah I learned that and it's weird
how it kind of your mind and your
behavior kind of play off each other you
know because if yeah the more and more
I'd not or I would avoid actively avoid
acting tired the last time the less
tired I feel yeah is weird but yeah
that's a big deal yeah and I always have
and still kind of do have I mean I'm
starting to figure it out
I used to think bread chocolate just
never gets tired just never does it but
now I'm trying to start to figure out
I'm sure you do you just deal with it in
certain ways to kind of map
you know like this way better than what
I'm used to is this part of the ongoing
debate it's whether jock was actually a
person human emotions you were talking
about you know when you're making that
connection of that light bulb going on a
lot of when we wrote this was you trying
to help people make the connection
sooner in life and have some sort of
template to get that light bulb to go on
that feel you have a losing emotion I
remember at some point early in my
military career it was kind of a cool
thing for senior guys the fry handle was
like a thing and you know what senior
enlisted or senior officers to like to
their juniors and and it was almost like
a technique like a leadership style and
I remember thinking every time I saw
every time I saw it in the back of my
mind I'm thinking how dumb that person
looked and how weak that person looked
but what for me what the connection was
is that I didn't make the connection at
how I looked when I did it because I
would think when I do that I look cool
and at some point I started to realize
like that feeling that I have about what
other people look like
that's what other people are seeing in
me and it's not cool when I do it I
don't do it the right way it's still the
same sign of weakness that I was it was
very easy for me to see it in other
people and really hard for me to see you
to myself when I made that connection
that's what made it much easier for me
to just stop acting like that and I was
never really one of those guys but
earlier in my career I'd almost kind of
like it copy the example that I was
seeing but it always bothered me because
it never seen it never made sense to me
and when I made the connection of I look
as stupid as everybody else that I think
looks dumb doing this to ever to other
people and that's when I made the
connection and just just kind of just
stopped doing it's pretty rare to really
very rare to fly off the handle but even
prettier to just show a bunch of emotion
because what most of the time when
people brought me problems but they
needed me to tell him like hey hey
there's no factor we can solve this this
is a solvable problem hey appreciate you
saying it let's work through the
solution and they were happier and more
satisfied than if I got emotional with
them I got all riled up and they walked
out and nothing got fixed yeah I think
I'm going back to Delta Charlie who I
talked about leadership strategy and
tactics my second platoon commander
could replace the guy who fired that guy
was so unflappable that
I I think I think I remember this time
like watching him get chewed out by
someone yeah you know like a like a
fleet officer you know and he was a
lieutenant he's a prior enlisted senior
chief but you know a lieutenant and some
whatever whatever we did or the whole
team did something happened and you know
he like you know Roger that sir and and
I just thought to myself Wow and then oh
he turned around and just the way he
handled it I'm like man that's legit and
I remember another time one of the guys
in the platoon got in a lot of trouble
like big trouble
borderline international incident
trouble and I remember I was expecting
him and it was somehow I ended up having
a conversation with him directly and and
I he said something like he said
something like you know you got to
expect things like this to happen this
like day like he took this whole thing
where people are worried about their
careers and the freaking this that the
other thing he goes you gotta expecting
things like you know you know chocolate
gonna expect things like this to happen
that was his reaction and I'm thinking
this is badass right here this is so
badass for him just to you know shrug
his head a little bit and saying any
guff expect things like this to happen
and I thought to myself damn imagine
this something crazy is happening and
you're the leader something totally
unexpected and you go you gotta expect
things like this to happen
that's so legit I tried to always be
that guy that said you know gotta expect
things like this to happen next section
relationships which by the way if if you
a tional on front so many answers boiled
down to you know okay well how's your
relationship with that person yeah my
boss does this that the other thing my
subordinate does that know how's your
relationship of that person and then you
hear the moment of silence you know cuz
they know that it's not good and then
you go okay let's start with building
relationship or you can actually have a
conversation with another human being so
relationships are your most powerful
tools for long-term success
this is true for everyone in life you
can't accomplish much on your own and
you need people in your life if you are
to reach your fullest potential since
time available to spend with people is
limited you need to get the most out of
every minute you have with them
interactions with family members should
strengthen relationships not weaken them
relationships with friends and
co-workers should be built up at every
opportunity spending time with the
people in your life should increase
trust esprit de corps and mutual support
and I would say one of the one of the
more poignant points I've made in my
life is telling people if I'm gonna have
a conversation with someone
I'm gonna build a relationship go into
it with that go into it with like I'm
gonna sit down with Dave look we have a
tough topic to discuss we got some
problems some issue came up what my goal
going this is where all relationships
gonna get better that's the goal and
that problems gonna get solved too but
my goal is to build that relationship
yeah if that's your mindset doing what
it says right here interactions with
family members should strengthen
relationships not weaken them think of
what that does to your interactions
think about what that does to your
family if what you're trying to do is
build not weaken friends and co-workers
build every time you talk to them build
that say that's the way you win and then
this last section is preparedness and
safety the world can be dangerous and
bad things happen violence is a daily
occurrence and can present itself
without warning you need to be prepared
both physically and mentally and ensure
the people closest to you are well
prepared as well you need to train
effectively to respond to a crisis
martial arts and self-defense be able to
protect yourself and your family from
physical violence weapons training be
able to protect your home from intruders
or intervene and escape accordingly if
required to in public
and lastly home safety emergency and
disaster have a plan and ensure everyone
in your home execute that plan under
stress rehearse that
and assess how prepared your family is
have all the required equipment and
supplies everyone in your family should
know CPR and basic life-saving steps
I heard Pat Mak Pat Mack said what do
you say he was doing one of his little
Instagram things and he said in your
family something along the lines of you
can have assets and liabilities well
think about that you have assets unless
so you're the people in your family if
something happens can either be an asset
or a liability where they at where they
at and what kind of effort are you
putting into your family to make sure
that when the time comes they're an
asset not a liability and here's what's
cool and I talked about this with
firearms training a lot look hey
firearms training is awesome and if you
need to defend yourself there is no
better solution then either okay I guess
avoidance is the best solution but if
you are confronted in a situation that
you cannot avoid firearm training is the
best thing for you right and having a
firearm but firearm training isn't only
good for that it helps with all kinds of
thing it helps your reaction time it
helps you learn to relax it helps you
control your emotions it helps you get
your breathing under because it helps
with all these other things what's the
same thing with family preparedness like
oh it's cool if you start it's cool in a
moment of turmoil if you have assets in
your family if your family members are
assets and not liabilities but not only
that as you teach them things its mates
built a stronger family unit it makes
them more prepared for life you're not
gonna be there all the time for your
daughters and your sons
they're gonna be out there on their own
in the world so have them be prepared
yeah and bad things are gonna happen
yeah in their life and they need to be
prepared for that I remember when we
were starting to put this section
together this prepare I know there's one
more but when we do this preparedness of
safety I was kind of thinking how am I
gonna how does this fit into the bigger
picture all these things are kind of
building on each other and the marginal
martial arts and the weapons training
kind of came very quick that made sense
hey just like you just described you
should be able to get away from a
problem if you can't you should be able
to take care of yourself or your family
and then we started talking about home
safety emergency just saying
we had this whole section on this
neighborhood community thing and at the
time it was it was a it was interesting
to figure out how it works
and we pieced it all together and we
added like two words to this after this
was all written before this thing going
on out this whole Cova 19 thing that
everybody is dealing with we added two
words but the rest of it was where
doesn't that how doesn't the stuff help
you every one of these things like you
just talked about the weapons training
helps you with breathing and I don't
like a like would you like to have a
control your heart rate yes you can
control your own heart rate I remember
learning that for the first time when I
was learning how to shoot the pistol and
my coach taught me how to breathe and
just and all of a sudden now this thing
is having impact across ways that it
never thought that there's any
connection and it isn't just responding
to the crisis which you absolutely need
to be able to do it's how that
infiltrates all the other things that
you're doing and all the stuff we talked
about too and you know certainly coming
full circle with what's going on now but
do you want to have a strong
relationship with the people in your
neighborhood to help respond to crisis
yes you do for any number of reasons
mm-hmm yes of the the last section is
neighborhood community impact develop
relationships with other leaders in your
neighborhood to protect against violence
disease or disaster and create a safe
environment for other residents that's
is that a good thing you know
is there anyone that's saying no isolate
yourself no don't be prepared to help
out do not have good relationship with
your neighbors so when something goes
wrong they won't be there to help you
and like I said we wrote this but we
wrote the word disease and disaster in
there because hey you know what we that
should be enough that that makes sense
but the rest of us it was just things
were thinking about is how do you be a
leader in your neighborhood has it
helped you how does it benefit you and
where else does that affect your life
and anybody that's in a community where
they know they can rely on other people
knows that that's important for a whole
some other reasons beyond just what
we're dealing with right now
yeah the network that you develop is how
you survive it's cover and move that's
what it is and you won't survive alone
dude I had that we had massive rains in
San Diego like ten days ago massive
rains up and where
sorry Carlsbad and that's a go thank you
and it was 5:30 in the morning I was
awake but I didn't and I hadn't piece
again I was going on and I heard the
rain coming down turns out my backyard
completely was flooding and I'm back
there at 5:30 with brooms and squeegees
just trying to keep the stuff from over
phone into the house and my right and my
left neighbor showed up at my house 10
minutes after they hope they got up they
checked their backyards they checked
each other's backyards and they came to
my house and saw me they both grabbed
rooms I didn't call him I didn't text
somebody and ask him they just made it
happen that cover move covered with two
relations yeah relationships and I
obviously would do the same thing for
them but that was a pretty impressive
thing for me too and I'm like all I did
was kind of look at the one guy who was
like just it were getting dumped on
water easy and I'm I go thanks bro and
he just kind of gave me the head nod
like nothing was really needed to be
said or anything he just was there it
was good to go man yeah there you go
that's what we do so those are the
things you get graded on the evaluation
and then we say most people are capable
of getting better once they know the
right attributes and understand what the
parameters are and how to assess their
performance a lot more people will get
closer to their goals can we actually
get there no we can't being eminently
qualified isn't a status we achieve or a
conclusion we reach being eminently
qualified as being on the path that does
not end it's the way of living life
where we accept that every single day
there is more to do the eminently
qualified human understands this and
recognizes that no matter what success
that has been achieved in one place
there is more to do elsewhere and as we
shift our focus from one to the other
that success we just achieved will begin
to erode our gains will decay and we
will have to rebuild what we have lost
the eminently qualified human knows
there is no end since there is no
stopping point on the quest to becoming
an eminently qualified human what are we
really trying to do the answer is simple
we are trying to get better every day
this require
growth in every facet of personal and
professional development
this requires action we have to turn our
words into action we have to turn our
ideas into action we have to turn our
skills into action we have to turn our
goals into action there are many
resources out there that help us
understand what we should how we should
behave and what is important what we
don't have is an evaluation system for
human beings that lets us define our
goal identify the critical attributes
required to achieve it and track our
progress along the way until now here is
the evaluation now we get into this
evaluation and all this does is it
breaks it down and this was this is I
guess the root of when I said hey we'll
have something out for everyone in a
week or whatever I said whatever
freaking horrible assessment I made of
how long this is gonna take this is what
we were actually talking about yeah and
what it does is it breaks down like what
you should be striving for we already
went through the categories but for
health
I'll could read a couple these just so
people get the general idea how physical
fitness activities that increase
cardiovascular strength and flexibility
and mobility daily actions that promote
physical health here's the score of zero
did not perform any activities that
contributed to my overall physical
fitness level you get a zero that day
here's the five highest score you can
get participated in training that
reached a level of exertion beyond my
perceived limits the most intense
physical training that I was capable of
performing set a new baseline for
maximum useful effort so you're going at
it got one for sleep and rest got one
for diet and nutrition here's the diet
nutrition did not eat properly and did
not provide any nutritional benefit to
perform critical daily tasks you get a
zero the other end of the spectrum
consumed ideal food intake and
maintained perfect adherence to diet or
fasting every calorie was optimal and
nothing was consumed that didn't
contribute to health and nutrition
allowing for a sustained peak
of performance throughout the entire day
that's what you're aiming for and that's
what the eminently qualified person does
yes and that's why a five yeah not a lot
of fibers around same thing with the
with the performance evaluation the
military you know it was that five was
like you know that dude you know is
legit and I look at that and like nope
that's nothing I'm not a five personal
development next one intellectual
Fitness time management financial
management personal goals you're gonna
get graded on each one of these the
intellectual Fitness one I'm gonna read
five because I like this one
listen achieved a major breakthrough in
understanding grasp a concept that made
significant impact my life my and my
ability to impart knowledge and skills
yours funny about that Dave have I ever
called you up and said hey or sent you a
text
I sent you a text the other day that was
an actual breakthrough an understanding
grasp a concept that made significant
impact in my life right that happens
like once every I don't know three
months to me that I actually do
something right oh dude it doesn't
happen often but those are really good
days man like that call with your left
text became a phone call became a long
phone call like those are good days man
those fives are when they happen are so
awesome they're so legit but they don't
happen no they don't
it hardly ever that you you you called
no you called me the other day and it
was maybe four or five days after we had
this legit conversation about a major
breakthrough and you go hey you got a
minute and I go oh damn I'm like this is
the call from Dave he's got the
breakthrough coming at me and it was
client call
you know let me know what's going on the
Klan I was like that's it I said I
thought you had a you know something
yeah so that one's all about you know
just personal development and getting
better the next one dispositor legit the
next one is professional development the
little definition productive impactful
meaningful and lucrative professional
life pursuit of and
growth in a career field that provides
financial security and freedom along
with the personal fulfillment
satisfaction performance here's a five
for performance outperformed all
expectations vastly exceeded
requirements and set new standard for
job performance completed all
assignments ahead of schedule with a
high degree of accuracy helped others
complete their assigned tasks consider
the impact of work up down and across
the team and contribute contribute fully
to maximize it that's a five oh it's
gonna be tough to get gonna be tough to
get here's a zero performed work below
the standard who did not work at all was
counterproductive regarding individual
and company-wide success I'm gonna
actually photocopy this and blow it up
for Echo Charles I'm just gonna set you
know like a goal with we also kind of
set a baseline you know that's zero you
know you didn't do anything and the five
is prettier but there's a little bit of
baseline to like what a one is cuz a one
on a scale of zero to five not a great
score yeah but a one is probably what a
lot of people are doing yeah you know
one is go yeah yeah yeah here's one
completed this is one performance in
your profession completed basic assigned
tasks identified areas for tasks where
additional guidance for additional for
additional guidance in order to complete
assignments but did not perform in a
noteworthy manner that's a lot and I
think what I think when we talked about
the Marine Corps yes
the Marine Corps minimum like when you
when you're below average you're doing a
deist you're doing it yeah that's right
doing your job is like the minimum and
you're kind of a below average marine
this one is like oh that's what I do
yeah and you be the most basic
qualification like the lowest level of
qualified because you know the the
stumped I think says unqualified marine
and that's why there's one of them like
there's not a lot of unqualified Marines
out there but everybody else if they're
qualified you're a one you're just
you're doing you're just doing your job
doing your job you're one you
you're doing your one and that's good to
go but if you're on the path to being in
the eminently qualified marine or animal
you have a long way to go that reap this
kind of Reed baseline what the scoring
system really was about you're not
getting threes or fours for doing your
job you get a one
you're gonna go above and beyond and you
got to extend yourself in ways you
didn't think you could to really improve
that score over time this is a scary
thing to do to yourself you know what
just made me scared echo Charles you're
gonna like this one because it has to do
with lifting you know what I'm saying
how many days you are you go in there
you look you got it done and you're kind
of proud that you got it done right yeah
yeah but it's like a 1 yeah like you did
you went and did your duty in the gym
you went you lifted you did whatever you
got a little hot but you know right how
often is it a 1 what's a 1 for physical
at the Bell physical physical fitness
here's a 1 engaged in basic fitness
routine or activity yeah yeah that's
pretty weak I usually do usually do more
than that yeah and then okay that's me
sounds like you you know you took like
an aerobics class yeah or like something
you could do in the middle of like a
barbecue or something like that but 2 to
4 is engaged in intense physical
activity and demanding exercise that
increased overall fitness levels while
addressing weaker areas that's that's
you give yourself between two and four I
bet I get a lot of threes yeah I better
get a lot of run I'm like yeah that was
a but you know I got better yeah
also sometimes I'm taking the
maintaining sometimes too yeah here's
the I think like well in my specific
case and I'm sure other people like this
too where it's kind of a gift and a
curse situation where that yeah one to
me you might as well not even work out
depending on how long you're putting on
ones and zeros but like a 1 is not worth
the work out we're not worth the mental
energy not worth the momentum or what
about just the discipline that you got
it done okay
yes I give some credit yes my curse yeah
right there to me it's like okay but no
I don't think about that kind stuff well
now I do net more but I'm just saying
routinely no but not like over the fact
that I did it I wish it played more of a
part in my mind
that way but it won a goal if it's it's
like three four sometimes fightin or why
even lift kind of thing but again that's
good because I get good workouts
routinely but the junk part is like if I
meant not in the mood to confront that
three four or five it's gonna just be a
zero straight up so I'm throwing up more
zeros than maybe I should be assumed
saying did not work out at all
you know those do you stretch if you
don't if you're not no let me say this
if you're not feeling like you don't
feeling like confronting a three four or
five which is a good way of putting it
because let's face it when you're
staring at a four because I got some
work some of my workouts doesn't matter
whether you want to put out or not if
you execute it you're doing a five yeah
but if you go in there and do it you're
doing at least a four point eight right
is maybe you could hold something back
but it's just gonna be pain it's just
gonna be pain so if you don't feel like
confronting that you go well I don't
feel like confronting that but I'm gonna
go stretch and improve my mobility at
least you get a one in the words of echo
Charles a1 is not nothing and it's
something yeah and look this we spent
and we built this out we use that model
and try to come up with a human version
of that you know this isn't designed to
punish you but it's a little bit of the
recognition like if you just kind of get
up you get down stairs to the gym and
you kind of knock out a workout hey look
that's good right but you're grading
yourself on this that's also just a one
you just sort of did the basics the the
based on of what you needed to do you
didn't get better you didn't improve you
didn't get faster do you get stronger
you might have maintained it's a hell of
a lot better than a zero but you also
gotta be honest or self and we're just
doing one of like 20 different
categories those ones as I look at those
ones that I'm like man I do a lot of
ones mm-hmm and that keeps me that keeps
me at a1 yeah and if I want that one to
become anything else there's a lot of a
lot more work that needs to be there and
again it's not you shouldn't punish
yourself for a1 but you got to recognize
that that's what you're doing
guess what you are you're a1 and you
want to get better you got
some work some real work in any of these
attributes this is we're talking right
now just one thing that's true for
humility it's true for leadership is
true for all these other things a one is
you coming up and you're doing your job
you're coming to work and you're doing
your job that's a one yeah
and that's good that's clever to give it
numbers like that too
cuz like who wants to be a one like who
who wants to roll in be like threw up a
one how much like one less to admit that
they've what they've been doing is a one
who wasn't really look in the mirror go
you know what man I've been cranking out
a lot of ones yes and I'm not as good as
I need to be the ones those ones don't
add up put it that way to nowhere and
here's part of like the I guess maybe my
it's partially an excuse really where
it's like why even go out there you know
why are out there meaning to the gym or
whatever why even go to the gym if it's
just gonna be a one if I if I can smell
the one coming on like why even bother
with that because what what's that gonna
do to my brain is it gonna get me a
little bit more used to throwing up once
how many times you've gone into doing
one you end up with a three yeah I mean
technically I'm going in with the goal
of a three and then I get like a four or
something like that but it's always like
a baseline high level high standard
workout that's it and that's why I used
to skip work out so much cuz I'm like
man I can't I can't do it if I had the
mindset I can just go in and stretch and
maybe warm up or if I ever had that
mindset it's like brother that's easy to
make it in the gym but then again I
guess thinking about it more that that
could just help you cuz you know when
you get in there yeah you're like oh I
read something the other day I think it
was you set up yourself up for three
minutes of practice on guitar like hey
you got to practice three minutes a day
that's it three minutes tell me you
can't find three minutes and what they
know the power behind this is if you get
out your guitar and you get it in your
hands and you you know pull out your
guitar pick and you start strumming it's
gonna be at least seven minutes right
it's gonna be 12 minutes the hardest
part was going I don't feel like
practicing for an hour right now you
don't need to practice for our practice
for three minutes and if that turns out
to be twelve cool
yeah yeah I guess like if you but then I
guess the the other part of my little
maybe it's partially excuse maybe it's
legit I don't know but it's like not
judge I don't want to get into that
routine of setting load bars you know as
a full of a workout you know what I was
you here's what happens to me I will be
like sore I'll have oh that's a zero
that's a rest day right there no I'll
have big Dom's anybody but what I'll do
is I'll go in and be like okay
maintenance day maintenance routine to
run the maintenance routine I'll just do
like some I'll row or hit a hit the
aerosol bike for a few hundred calories
or whatever and then just yeah kind of
take a that's a it's a one well but it's
not a zero yeah but then again if it's
like if you have Dom's and you need
recovery that's the DOM is just an
indicator that you need recovery kind
you know there's more to it than that
fritter but it's it
you mean indicate it right so if you for
real believe for real belief not
convinced yourself or you know maybe
makes you but if you furball Eve that
you need recover recovery and you go in
and just to get the blood flowing get
some stretch some mobility stuff
whatever that could wind up not being an
exertion hard hardcore workout but
literally achieving the goal of that
workout seem saying cuz if you do some
hardcore workout with recovery so you
could get a foreign recovery to get it
for like you're the little bility tech
scenario it seems like you could yeah
alright next sections character and
leadership and again you know the
emotional controls in there
the zero for emotional control has lost
control of emotions when interacting
with people around me during this
stressful encounter setback any progress
toward controlling emotions actually
should have been a low stress encounter
right that would be the worst you're in
a low stress encounter and you get
emotional you have to change something
because the other end of the spectrum is
maintained to maintained emotions under
duress in the most difficult situation
possible cuz that's true like that's
that you get credit for that you get a
fight things are going crazy you
maintain was able to immediately
identify my own red flags or those are
people around me detach and make an
ideal decision to get the best possible
outcome
that otherwise would have been missed
the best possible outcomes good yeah and
that's under most difficult situation
yeah cuz that's easier to follow you
actually need your environment needs to
help you get a five oh if you're not
dealing they start again you know five
of them yeah and that's why the one is
what the one is like maintained control
of my emotions in normal situations was
aware of periods of heightened emotions
that did not let them get out of control
if you had a normal day and nothing
really went on your day you'd even have
the chance for revive so you get a want
you you your two one yeah and you talk
about hey this is kind of this is a
little scary thing we're like the scary
ones are the one like dude that's most
of my days well yeah guess what you
weren't in even in a situation to
respond like that you did not have this
overwhelming situation where you're tons
of emotions we're coming out because I'm
just a regular normal day what you don't
get credit for that either yeah you know
it's cool you add Jiu Jitsu to your day
and all of a sudden you can get a - for
sure - for sure because you're gonna get
emotional like there's gonna be stress
moments you get you know you're getting
whatever that's character and leadership
relationships is in there that emotional
one you know that was a that was a good
little addition when you say the best
possible outcome because because let's
face it son some people can delude
themselves with the emotional outbursts
you know just kind of how you mentioned
like some people they do their little
emotional tirade and then they're they
kind of feel solid like yeah I probably
look pretty powerful in that moment so
they almost have this little sense of
pride but they ignore kind of the
outcome you know they just they focused
too much in my opinion on how they felt
at the moment and then they're kind of
recalling that feeling and they did they
kind of chalk it up as a little bit of a
little success moment they're given
themselves a five when they really
didn't get the best possible outcome
yeah because they saw some movie where
it looked cool or whatever saying I look
like Christopher Walken or whatever
whoever he looked like or whatever
meanwhile the outcome is all terrible
you seem saying yeah that's a good leave
it at that
relationships quality time with your
family quality time with friends and
co-workers the next one's preparedness
and safety you know did you train
martial arts
did you do weapons training did you do
fire safety emergency training did you
get connect with your neighborhood in
your community here's a here's a here's
a score of two to four what for martial
arts was part of aggressive training and
significant learning that advanced my
ability for self-defense learned
important new skills and techniques and
made major improvement
I really hit that now in the beginning
it's easier to hit next you're learning
more days yeah but dang like once
someone's a black belt like echo yeah
weapons training let's see if I'm biased
when I wrote these participated in an
aggressive training and significant
learning that advanced my weapons
proficiency in comfort acquired new
equipment and skills that enhance self
confidence and ability with self to
Finnell actually that's that's a that's
solid that well-written yeah it's solid
but here's that did you write that I'm
trying to think of I thought I might
skew it or I thought we might skew it
towards like hey as long as you shot
today you're good yeah like as long as
you got rounds downrange but that's a
one you think well your engage in
limited here's a one and weapons
training engage in limited training to
maintain proficiency but took no steps
towards acquiring needed weapons or
advanced proficiency that's that means
you got on the range and you still get
just a one mmm you know maybe dry fired
he still get a little bit of a one yeah
that's what I'm saying what if you
didn't go to the rain but you try fired
maybe this is what we're saying it's
hard to get it's hard to win it's hard
to be a three four five yeah and then it
goes we explain this yeah yeah exactly
exactly this really easy to be like oh
yeah you know I was shooting twice a
month like gross or twice month doesn't
get you there ya know
wrap up to kind of explain the
evaluation and then what to do if you
fall off the path and this leads to I
think this part about the evaluation
about how this works is actually kind of
important to think about how you are
gonna approach that matrix we just
talked about and how you were gonna
assess yourself and what it really means
to give yourself any of these grades and
what's really going on there
well it says it is designed is not
designed just to grade yourself but also
so you know that you're trying what
you're trying to become it requires
humility in a brutally honest
self-assessment no one else is scoring
you don't compare yourself to others
this is about your capacity compared to
your performance Oh
echo Charles likes that it's your
capacity compared to your performance
it's you against you ask yourself how
much effort you put into something and
measured against what you are capable of
the more you put into something the more
progress you will make this is different
from person to person and different for
yourself as time goes on if you've never
exercised before in your life and you
walk a mile you may have exerted
yourself close to the limit that might
be a five that same workout might be a
one for someone who's been in the gym
for years it might even be it might even
be a zero but as you get better and
improve that one mile walk no longer
represents your maximum capacity so it
no longer represents a five for you as
you move down the path towards an enemy
qualified human your capacity will
increase as a result improving actually
becomes more difficult over time you
have to work even harder and do more to
make even the same amount or even less
of an improvement this system only works
if you understand what you're capable of
and if you're honest about what you have
done being easy on yourself doesn't help
you or the people in your life you must
commit you must stay on the path so yeah
we all know that the stronger you get
the harder it becomes to get stronger
the better you get at jujitsu the harder
it becomes to get better at jujitsu
which is weird because there's a there's
a ramped up session even with working
out then you
don't think about this but when someone
just starts working out for a little
while they can't do really the exercise
they got Dom's every day and they're
just not really making the gains but
then after a little while they start
going Oh same thing with jiu-jitsu you
start learning and all of a sudden you
can process it like I think you're
optimum
I think where you're learning the most
is probably when you're a blue belt do
you think yeah it depends on what you
mean by what you're learning so you're
learning the most information is being
absorbed the big strides Reince yeah I
think I think you're right the white
belt that's when you're learning the
most moves until you know I think that
but you can't assimilate that maybe it's
a high end of white belt yeah yeah I'm
sure it's around in that zone in working
out it is a common thing well I think in
trainers or in the training community
that's a normal thing
it's called newbie games so you get
gains in the beginning like way more
than 20 and you know so like if you're
advanced lit lifter bodybuilder whatever
um yeah your games come close hmm but
the new guys new be gains that's what
they call it that's what it Oprah I'm
just saying it's a thing next section
what do you do when you fall off the
path you can't and will fall off the
path that happens everyone sometimes we
do to ourselves sometimes life hits or
something we didn't see coming
people get sick accidents occur things
happen the world we can't control and
those things can push us off the path
but you can control how you react when
you fall off what you do to get yourself
back on the path it's up to you the
situation doesn't dictate what happens
to you you dictate the situation you
decide when you fall off the path ask
yourself why why are you not doing the
things you know you should do an
unsparing self-assessment identify
corrective measures and ruthlessly
implement those measures take action get
back on the path for anything that
affects your health or mind of your
health for anything that affects the
health of your mind or body see your
doctor or professional in the field but
you sometimes you got to go to a
mechanic that's a doctor
that's a psychologist this is not a time
to rely on friends or family members you
need professional help so get it that
being said there are protocols
to help get you back on the path these
are some protocols and again I talked
about where these came from
doo doo I'll do this one I don't want to
do them all but I'll do this one break
up I don't I don't know why I'm doing
this one because there's like you you
put out a video and everything of this
one well then here's the here's the
here's the clean version right here's
like here's what you do break up my
relationship is over and I don't know
what to do
number one detach your emotions are your
enemy during a breakup
they will not enable you to make good
decisions or make good choices of course
this will be hard the core of
relationships is built on emotions so in
order to detach from your emotions take
a step back look at the situation from
someone else's point of view you might
think no one else understands and you
are right they don't understand the
emotions you have but that means the
emotions are not blinding them try to
see that if you have trouble detaching
go to step one a step one a it might
also help to let your emotions out but
you're so in a way that does not affect
the situation find a private place where
you can scream cry or otherwise release
your emotions try physically exerting
yourself to get rid of the emotional
aggression get a punching bag go for a
run be repeat step one a as needed
gotta get those emotions out sometimes
that's a way to detach to assess the
person you have separated from and
evaluate who they actually are so this
is why it's simple you have to detach
before you do this assess the person you
have separated from and evaluate who
they actually are the truth is that
person is not who you thought they were
the person you cared about does not
exist the idea that this person was a
trustworthy faithful companion is not
true you created an ideal around their
framework but they do not actually exist
they have proven they do not exist by
their actions do not dwell on what it
was because it wasn't
do not dwell on what it could have been
because it couldn't it was a lie which
is this you see so many and III guess
I'm gonna talk about it from a guy
perspective because in the team's you'd
get guys that would break up with a girl
and it so I saw it over and over again
from the guy perspective and that's what
they do well but it was she was so good
and it we could have and it's always
that hanging on to this lie and it's a
lie it's not true that person doesn't
exist that girl that you thought you
were gonna marry and everything's gonna
be a no no not gonna work because she
didn't exist step number three be
thankful be thankful that this lie was
uncovered now instead of later before
you invested even more into that person
that person who you now realized was not
who you thought they were be thankful
that you found out when you did that
this person is untrustworthy be thankful
that you can now move forward
oh man it's tough to tell to have to
tell that to the crying human know step
number four wish them luck yes perhaps
it is a final conversation perhaps it is
a note but wish them luck they are going
to need it do not harbor any ill
feelings those ill feelings do you no
good
let them remember you not a suspect for
vindictive slave to your emotions and
whims but as a good mature person ready
to move on positively in the world and
that's one of those things where look
I'm gonna continue on before I get into
this walk step number five walk away you
know this person is not who you wanted
them to be and you can't change that so
walk away move on don't look back step
number six don't look back your mind
will page play tricks on you you will
lie to yourself tell yourself that maybe
it can work and maybe I was wrong and if
I can just try one more time maybe he or
she will change no that's not happening
they aren't going to change
and the fact the matter is the more you
crawl back to them the more you belittle
yourself and push them further away
don't do it walk away don't look back
and that's that's the part that I was
gonna kind of venture into is if you're
in one of these situations where you
like all if only I could say one more
thing if I and that is what drives
people away that's what they don't
respect and they don't like so the best
possible thing you can do is say hey
good luck I'll see you later
walk away and don't look back the minute
you look back and throw out the lifeline
and beg for whatever they did they want
to get rid of you even more so the best
possible thing you can do the win-win
move is walk away and don't look back
it's the win-win move and then seven get
back on the path wake up early work out
read write learn play an instrument
train jiu-jitsu eat clean clean your
room clean your car get ahead at work
when someone breaks your trust when
someone breaks our trust we question
ourselves we think our judgment is bad
because we put our faith in this person
who hurt us so how do you build that
trust back with yourself look back and
learn from the relationship see the
mistakes you made and the red flags you
missed then look for them next time
around recognize that there are plenty
of people out there in the world that
are trustworthy and faithful go find one
of them move forward in that
relationship with a clean slate
don't bring baggage so there's your
protocol and I think the humorous
protocol the original protocol was like
order Pete you know I made something up
off the top of my head but this is the
legit protocol if you can execute this
it's hard to execute because people get
all wrapped around there they get
wrapped around this thing so deep and so
hard so but it's a protocol mm-hmm it's
a protocol it's a way to handle these
things
we gotta weigh in here to handle death a
protocol for death what do you do when
someone dies here's the protocol what
are you doing you have some kind of
financial problems what's the protocol
what do you do how do you handle it what
do you do when you have a betrayal
of trust right because it's not always
in a relationship like a like a spouse
or a girl an intimate relationship that
you have a betrayal trust I was gonna
happen in a in a work environment
sometimes it can happen just with
friends so betrayal of trust what do you
do then how do you handle what's the
protocol we got problems going on at
work what's the protocol how do I handle
it what do what if I said or did
something that hurts someone's feeling
and I need to make it right in other
words what if I need to make an apology
what's the protocol to apologize how do
we you know some people go through their
whole lives they don't know how to
apologize how what do I do when there's
an accident or there's an illness like
severe medical diagnosis what do i do
how do I handle that what's the protocol
what's the protocol for addiction what
do we do how do we handle this what's
the protocol for trauma I suffered a
psychological trauma I don't know how to
deal with it what do I do that and again
look these these topics of trauma these
topics of addiction look that's why we
say you might need to get professional
help in fact you should but even when
you get professional help you're gonna
see these protocols protocols to follow
and then there's this last one the
unknown what do I do when I don't know
what to do something bad happened I
don't know where to start
I'll go through this this is the
strategy protocol every scenario cannot
be addressed so this is the protocol for
what to do when you don't know what to
do one start by taking a step back
detach take a breath and look around
make sure you assess everything that is
happening to think about your
possibility think about what your
possibilities are and what decisions you
could make right now and what are the
likely outcomes of those decisions three
write it down what does success look
like in this situation how can you get
there
how long should it take do you know
anyone who can provide guidance or
advice for work the plan take action
that moves you forward
don't stay stagnant don't dwell take a
small step towards what you think is the
best decision not a giant step because
you don't know exactly what is going on
this is a step that allows you to assess
again before you decide on what to do
next five push forward and then pause
and reassess again repeat and press
forward to the point of friction press
until you reach the point that you see a
new opportunity or need to pull back and
reassess again six allow yourself room
to maneuver when it gets hard don't
surrender don't give up don't quit then
you haven't failed all it means you need
to regroup Andrea tak you've learned
you've gained experienced and you're
still alive there's gonna be things in
life that you don't expect and you don't
know what to do and there's the protocol
yeah the the beauty of the protocols and
we were writing them you can expect at
the very beginning is that even with
death and illness you are in control
maybe not everything maybe you're not in
control of everything but you have so
much more control then you might give
yourself credit for and you have to take
control of that situation you are in
control of how you react and how you
respond and running through those
protocols is you being in control and
you talked about hate that's hard
walking away from the girl the one the
one you know is the right one for you
but it turns out they're not that's hard
but if you if you can do that if you can
control that situation think of how much
more in your life you can control and
that's what those protocols are about as
you being control of these situations as
much as you can yeah we've all said that
as a National Front to a bunch of our
clients you know what do we do now what
do we do with covet 19 we can't control
this we control how we respond that's
what we control if it's right you
absolutely control how you respond the
book wraps up you're on the path you're
seeing the results of your hard work and
your efforts are paying off unmitigated
daily discipline in all things is not
just a saying it's your life your health
is excellent your work and personal
performance is exceeding expectations
you are leading in all aspects of your
life so what now
thank those who helped you along the way
take stock in what you have achieved
then go harder lead lead your family
your community your country lead
everyone and everything in your world
lead others to the path show them the
way and you called me out on that you
said hey hey there's one - Road it's so
good
you said go harder I was like yes I like
it and then it closes out unmitigated
daily discipline in all things it's the
only way we've got downloadable
evaluation forms at Jocko publishing
dot-com slash downloads so you can take
those forms and you can start filling
them out for yourself and there you go
so on 174 podcasts 174 I said to think
about where you're at are you really a
five really or are you a two can you aim
for a three or a four is there any
quality that you can reach five on a
good question let's try let's try cuz we
might not be able to reach five but we
can absolutely get better we can
absolutely continue to pursue the quest
that never is going to end trying to
become an eminently qualified human
being and if you live that way if you
live trying to become an eminently
qualified human being what you'll end up
doing is living an eminently honorable
life and a life eminently worth living
there you go
anything else Dave well echo Charles you
know what that means
if since it looks like we are attempting
to head down the path what do you got
what recommendations do you have that
can help us you know proceed shall we
say I've got a few so first thing as
always is jiu-jitsu although at this
current exact moment in time we're doing
a lot less if any jujitsu because we've
got to stay safe because that's part of
it - you got a Stacee Jaxx that's
probably one of the things this whole
thing is about preparedness yeah prepare
a safe give yourself another unless this
is how we're gonna do it all these
things I'm about to say right now are
all included in the path like their path
uh what do you say like worthy or
conclusive
whatever path worthy and path inclusive
you say you can say both and pick your
pick your pronoun just an open s not a
pronoun you can pick your wordage pick
your verbage yes so jujitsu when we can
part of it for sure you say martial arts
students I feel like you were like
fighting your pan back cuz you just want
to write jujitsu but you just gotta go
martial arts no that's not necessarily
actually that's not true okay cuz
jujitsu is a is definitely really good
but you gotta learn that boxing that
wrestling you can't get five by just
just limiting yourself to just digit you
straight up totally and being rigid to
it yeah yeah you've got to do it doing
more yes sir
all right well but we are doing jujitsu
yes sir big-time it's it includes you
did too included but not limited to will
say that no no all right so when you do
when you do just so you need a gate and
a rash guard because these are the
uniforms so get the best ski best rash
guard from origin origin main coms where
you can get all this stuff so these rash
guards
a bunch of other cool stuff on there
also jeans mm-hmm
so getting origin made jeans
american-made denim does improve the
community around you that is a good very
valid point
yes very valid point and right now it is
mm April 21st 2020 and there's there's a
pandemic going on
we at origin the origin team has shifted
to making face coverings is what they're
officially called because we don't want
to imply that they have the medical
qualities that an n95 mask has on but
the government has recommended and
medical professionals have recommended
that people wear face coverings so we
are making a massive amount of face
coverings right now so people that have
ordered jeans we actually shut down
those lines right now but we are seeing
the light at the end of the tunnel and
we are ready to open the jeans line back
up the gay lines back up and we'll be
doing that shortly so just check origin
main comm if you want a pair of jeans if
you want a pair of boots we're there
we're making them we had to do a little
adjustment because of the demands of
this pandemic put on America so made
some adjustments but in the end we're
gonna make we're gonna make American
products we're gonna make american-made
jeans geez rash guards t-shirts don't
mind you it's so appreciate everyone's
patience as we you know try and support
America through this pandemic scenario
also supplementation keep you on the
path keep you in the game big time so
what do we got Mulk
additional protein in the form of a
dessert by the way discipline and
discipline go essentially the same thing
in different what delivery
method yeah yeah it is essentially the
same thing in different delivery methods
that's for your brain yeah yeah
discipline go or RTD ready-to-drink
that's kind of is that a that's like a
term from that industry right like you
wouldn't say hey can you grab me an RTD
no you'd say grab me a can ago yeah yeah
so yeah but but in the industry which I
had to learn about it's called RTD ready
to drink crack it open and drink it so
yeah we got all that we got Molk or your
kid milk we got chocolate tea and by the
way all these products you can get them
all mine at origin Mein Kampf or you go
to Vitamin Shoppe if you go to a vitamin
shop in your AO you can get some what's
your what's your your biggest you you
look like you want to say something
about yeah so I'm on the Moultrie nobody
knows that I would like to think that
I'm well associated with discipline and
go and I thought was without somebody
said I thought it was ready to deploy
cans because I grabbed them and I'd go
with them oh sorry but I'm on another
train right now I don't know if I'm
supposed to be announcing this train but
I'm on the cold war train oh yeah so
that cannot go unstated that the that
supplement the Cold War supplement right
now
there is I would say a requirement right
now there's something that is part of my
current repertoire yeah well especially
you know a month ago we're traveling all
the time
and I was but I was at Ground Zero yeah
for I did a gig in San Francisco Seattle
in New York like the three first kind of
areas where the pandemic broke out but
you know also in every one of those
place places shaking between a thousand
and two thousand people's hands totally
in each one of those places traveling on
an airplane with a bunch of other people
in between those places so yeah you've
got to have that immune system engaged
get your cold war on yeah I feel like
cold war is more of a tank than a train
I'm saying I do because yeah more I feel
like protective armor yeah so maybe tank
yeah be there
does cold-war tank does that even sound
like a thing though cuz mole train
sounds like a thing yeah and deep plane
kind of sounds like something to breath
deeply no least it sounds like something
you tried to implement
oh it's implemented put it that way
indeed alright nonetheless alright cool
yes these are all things approved by the
path 100% hundred five percent really
let's face it also we have a store it's
called jhaqo store where you can get
items to represent while you're on the
path in quarantine or not I'm saying as
time goes on you said the same
anyway we got shirts on their hoodies
more rash guards discipline equals
freedom you know all these goods all
this good stuff hoodies truck hats
truckers hats beanies flex it all that
stuff the boxes forgot about the boxes
the boxes are we put we've put together
a bunch of boxes for the live gigs I was
doing the live gigs got cancelled so we
got a bunch of these boxes we just
reassemble I put some of them up there
and they sold out so we just assembled
some more of them so if you want to get
those boxes there's a warrior kid box
and there's a deaf core box there like
they have the flags you're gonna warrior
kid flag you know just four equals
freedom flag in there then they got a
bunch of other cool things it's like a
little toolkit for the path that's what
it is
mmm-hmm yeah that's what it felt like
when I got mine I like yes sure oh yes
we have those all on jaco store.com also
subscribe to this podcast if you haven't
already because it's important in many
ways mmm arguably yeah the real arguably
and i'll tell you what if you're 2 hours
and whatever many minutes deep into this
thing you haven't subscribed well I
don't know did you as a person
we got some other podcasts we got the
thread which is with Darryl Cooper
martyr made so you can check that one
out
we got grounded podcast which is a
podcast about jiu-jitsu in life the
thread is about
the threat is about the threads between
history and the past and how they tie in
to what's happening right now in the
world so that's been cool the warrior
kid podcasts for the warrior kids and
then we also from the warrior kid
podcast we got some warrior kids so
young Aiden Irish hopes ranch comm he's
making soap he's making killer soap
that's the name of the soap oh yeah and
if you get that kind of soap and it will
definitely give you the capability to
stay clean which is part of the path too
by the way
don't be all dirty yeah I guess you've
got to be willing to get dirty but not
stay dirty you will stay clean
that's what you know stay but you with
varying levels of capability to endure
dirt in terms okay put it into context
there anyway also we have a youtube
channel for video video version of this
podcast and other and excerpts as well
this turns out to be a cool way I think
to the podcast be more immersed in the
conversation I think you can see what
good deal Dave looks like yeah man and
good looking guy at the end of the day
for sure um so yeah YouTube channel
chocolate castle official now check mark
you know the check mark just so that you
can recognize the real one from the
imposter see yeah yeah it's not utility
Jocko motivation channel yeah and we
also have psychological warfare iTunes
Google Play and mp3 platforms if you
want to check that out we have flipside
canvas Dakota Meyer making cool things
to hang on your wall that will keep you
on the path got a bunch of books
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual Dave Burke you were the one of
the first people to read that you might
have even been the first person to read
that but you get some credit there
appreciate that that book that should be
an RTD Field Manual ready to deploy
maybe not the ready anytime immediate
reference to any issue you got that
thing stays with you it does not go in
the shelf things are ready to deploy
yeah that's I like it it's just about
everything I get asked
I can answer it in that bucket bro so
pretty straightforward also got way the
warrior kid one two and three are your
kids still reading that book they are
reading that book we did number three
finished number three last night last
chapter with Matt last night didn't want
to go sighs first time getting through
it no but they're ready for four they're
super pumped because you had some new
word kid podcasts come out about that
yeah Johnny Kim was on one yes because
who doesn't what kids not what kids not
saying I want to be a just a Navy SEAL a
doctor and an astronaut whatever like
every kid what else could he had on
there I guess he needs to be a fireman a
firefighter what else oh and a pro
baseball player right needs to knock
those out come on bro so we also have
discipline equals freedom field man Oh
Mikey the dragons don't forget about
miking the dragons there's a bunch of
police officers right now around the
country that are doing this kind of
reading of Mikey in the Dragons I seen a
bunch of so I appreciate them all spread
in the words disability was pretty
filled Manuel extreme ownership in the
dichotomy in leadership the leadership
lessons from combat that I wrote with my
brother LAIV babban so check those out
if you haven't gotten them exelon front
is our leadership consultancy what we do
is solve problems through leadership go
to echelon front comm yes we are alive
yes we are engaged right now we're doing
it digitally how's that working out for
you Dave
awesome so good so legit it has been
awesome yeah it's it's a instead of us
flying out and spending five hours in an
airplane to get to talk to you for two
hours or three hours
no we're there two hours or three hours
we're face to face with you on the
Internet we're answering your questions
and since we didn't waste five hours
coming out there we're gonna do it again
with you next week and the week after
that so it's been a really cool
transition and I'm sure you know we'll
go back when when the pandemic is over
we'll go back and we'll do live stuff
but man if we aren't we are completely
having such such an incredible impact
that we weren't able to achieve before
because we were always logistically
moving around and now it's like no we're
right here you know I was I was talking
to a client today and I was doing an
example of what it's like when the
subordinates are blaming up the chain of
command and so the the woman that has
the question you know I had I was saying
I was pointing right at the camera I was
right in the cameras face and I'm like
yelling and it's just if if that was no
no if that wasn't on the internet you
know she would have been whatever ten
rows back and I would have been you know
there would've been a disconnect there's
a little bit of a disconnect no I'm
right you know I'm just you know joking
around now I go this is what happens
when you don't tell the team what's
going on they start saying you don't
understand you don't give us the support
we need and I'm doing it right the
camera it's wrist you know it's funny
I'm just having fun with it but that's
like an effect you don't get you don't
get that life so it's been very cool and
the other thing that we've really kind
of kind of just gone after right now and
gotten after is EF online so EF online
which was which was a very static
platform of hey you can come on here you
can go through these courses and you
know we got great feedback on the
courses but right now since we're all
since we all have this opportunity to
step up we're doing this live stuff on
it well we're doing it three times a
week right now we're stepping it up and
what's great about it is once again look
there's two hundred people or 150 or a
hundred people that are sitting on the
Internet during a call and people are
gonna ask a question right there on the
spot can say hey Jocko I got this you
know I got a subordinate that's doing
this what do you think I should do okay
boom here you go
oh well explained give me some more
detail on that so it's like on the
podcast you do QA we do QA I read the
question but that's just my
interpretation of questions there's no
feedback loop so when live EF online
it's like hey explain what you mean
explain the relationship you have give
me some expands to give me some
more commentary on what it is you guys
are trying to achieve so you get these
detailed questions going on and by the
way you got a bunch of people there
we're all listening to each other and
everybody is going oh yeah I had that
happen oh here's another way to handle
it so it's been phenomenal go to EF
online.com if you want to check that out
we got the leadership primer we got
immediate action drills we got Q&A is
going on so check that out the muster we
are still going to go live at some point
the one in Phoenix cancelled but
September 16th and 17th in Dallas Texas
or sorry Phoenix Arizona September 16th
and 17th and Dallas Texas December 3rd
and 4th many of the people that were
going to come to Orlando which was
cancelled just moved to either Phoenix
or Dallas so those are gonna sell out
quicker than normal everything we've
ever done has sold out so go to extreme
ownership comp for details if you want
to come to one of those events and we
have EF overwatch and EF Legion so
taking veterans that understand the
principles we talked about and placing
them either at in executive positions
through EF overwatch or front-line
leaders through EF Legion comm EF
overwatch com
come and find the leaders you need to
help your team win in those locations
and if you're a vet go to EF if you're a
vet go to EF Legion and sign up go to EF
Legion we got companies calling us right
now that need to hire look there's a lot
of companies that are laying people off
there's also a lot of companies that
business has gone through the roof that
are hiring right now go to EF Legion
comm so we can get you out there and the
world can can know about you that are
looking to hire good people and if you
haven't had enough of my droning
overbearing voice or you haven't had
enough of echos the aggressive ramblings
or Dave's hyper enthusiastic viewpoints
then you can get more of us on the
interwebs
on Twitter on Instagram and on 9f
Eisenbach Dave is that david r burke ber
ke echo is adequate Charles and I am at
Jocko willing and to everyone that's out
there right now overseas in uniform
protecting our great nation thank you
and to police and law enforcement
firefighters paramedics EMTs dispatchers
correctional officers Border Patrol
Secret Service thank you for protecting
us here at home and also to all the
doctors and nurses and medical personnel
that are on the front lines every day
right now risking disease to fight
disease thank you for stepping into the
breach and everyone else out there the
path is hard and it is filled with
obstacles and you may never get to the
top in fact you probably won't but keep
striving keep pushing keep maintaining
unmitigated daily discipline in all
things by going out there every single
day and getting after it and until next
time this is Dave and Ecko and Jocko out